welcome everybody to the i'm not a gm
speed chess championship i'm grand
master robert hess alongside me the one
and only grandmaster mon hamilton
amman you had the call for the first
match this is just our second
how you feeling about the prime time
matchup between danny wrench and
lawrence trent
well first of all hello robert hello
everybody
it's good to be back for the uh as you
said the second match here
i think lawrence against danny is is a
lot of people's
closest matchup in in the first round i
want to say because
uh you know everyone knows about
lawrence danny and
you know they've been going back and
forth on twitter a little bit as well so
feels like there's a little bit of heat
behind this match but
i honestly had this match up as one of
the closest to expect from round one
robert
absolutely and they are the 710 matchup
if i'm not mistaken
but before we continue talking to
players let's remind everyone of the
format because this
is a single elimination knockout they
will have 75 minutes of the longer time
which will five minute plus one second
increment followed by 45 minutes of
three plus one
and finally 25 minutes of bullet in one
plus one of course the winner making it
to the quarter finals and the prizes not
bad eh
amman seems like pretty good paydays for
these players who really
it's pride at stake but also some prizes
yeah i mean i
i i was thinking about maybe just
putting my gm title on hold and seeing
if i could sneak in this tournament uh
because those
prizes don't look half bad robert well
if only this tournament had begun a few
years earlier because you've
cemented that gm title for a while now
but
let's look at the bracket because you
mentioned this one as being the toss-up
that everyone would be a bit conflicted
about
and when i look from top to bottom here
we know that greg shahadi has made his
way
into the quarterfinals what other
matchups catch your eye here
well um first of all the tournament has
changed a little bit from the first
edition which is that it's not only
ims competing in this event we have a
lot of other streamers personalities and
and a lot of familiar names for for a
lot of the twitch viewers here
i think a very underrated matchup which
will be
insanely close is actually right
underneath that greg match-up
tiny assassinative against uh kostya
kavitsky so i think that match is going
to be
very very close and we also have eric
rosen against sagar shaw and to be quite
honest i don't know what to expect from
cigar it's not someone that i've seen
play in this format too much and i think
that that might be uh just kind of a
dark horse matchup to look out for for
sure because we don't know the bullet
skills in particular
you know all these players are very
strong but if they're not well practiced
online that could be a problem
and one matchup that i'm really looking
forward to is the one beneath this one
with
lars oscar howe could take out alina
kashinskaya of course alina
under seated at number 14 considering
she made her way to the finals last year
and she's looking not just to repeat
that but even win this whole thing
yeah no that that is a criminally
underseated
i would say alina is very very dangerous
in every format which is what she
demonstrated in the first edition
for sure and well you know while we have
been talking about some other matchups
today we do have
danny against lauren so i'm pretty
pumped for this one
it's danny getting ready playing a bit
of bullet in fact winning this bullet
game that
i have on my computer in front of me and
lawrence was playing bullet himself so
you think they're a little bit nervous
here i i think that they
they both seem to have the same idea
that neither guy wants to
weigh into this match a little light
they're looking to get the highest
rating possible even right up to
the start of the game clock to
intimidate the the opponent
and even the big boss had to have that
fair play cam going on where
they're on screen right of course in
front of them so we can see their faces
but also their surroundings to ensure
that they are competing fairly we know
that they are but it's just taking those
precautionary measures
just to uphold fair play and well the
play
hopefully is a bit better than fair i
think that we would like to see these
players
give their best because lawrence and
danny they're not going to hold any
punches
as you mentioned them on on twitter
they've been going at it
so what do you think we'll see over the
board itself
well i think one of the interesting
things about lawrence as a competitor is
that i find him to be a very
um almost like a like a he plays chess
like he plays poker maybe he's very
emotional
and driven by his emotions so if he has
a good game he's going to ride that
momentum into the next game
whereas if he has a bad game it might
affect his next game in a negative way
more than it might affect other players
so
you know you live by the sword dive by
the sword but i think that's one of the
things that really defines
lawrence as a player that if he gets on
a roll if he's feeling himself he's a
showman and
uh we could really see you know in any
section if he
wins one two games in a row he's really
going to stick it to
danny so i think that that the emotional
side of things is really going to come
into play as for the
bullet as you mentioned we saw both of
these guys warming up with bullets so
maybe maybe it speaks to the fact that
that could be the defining segment of
this match yeah i like what you said
there
about the emotions because speaking of
emotions danny sometimes gets a little
too attached to certain openings as you
know full well
from beating me and danny you and eric
teamed up
from the chess broad chess com showdown
where you all won but sometimes he gets
a little too attached to certain
openings and certain ideas so i know
that he loves a good queen sacrifice
sometimes it's an inopportune moment
and he'll need to reign that in because
at his best danny can beat anybody in
this field
and i i really do believe that this
match is a toss-up i would
actually give a slight nod to danny as
objectively as i possibly can be i think
that he's
a little bit stronger a little bit
faster than lawrence's these days
yeah yeah and i i think one of the
important characteristics that
you do not want to have in a match like
this is
actually stubbornness uh when when
you're playing an opening and it's not
going
your way especially when you get down to
the bullet if you're playing something
in five minute
it's not working three minutes not
working it's definitely not going to
work in bullet it's going to get worse
as the time gets lower so
you won't be able to adapt have a few
options ready
that hey if something's not working out
you know you can play something else
because
i think the the stubbornness of certain
players being as you said attached to a
certain opening too much
is actually their detriment i completely
agree
and while we do have what will be a
promising match ahead of us today i want
to remind everybody that we do have
more action in the i'm not a gm speeches
championship
international master levy rosman better
known as gotham chess throughout the
twitch sphere
taking on james canty the third that is
an im
versus nm national master match up and
i'm on just to do a quick
little preview of that of course on
paper levy is the heavy favorite
james very popular commentator and
streamer in his own right what are his
chances like
yeah well obviously in this uh this
tournament because it's changed a little
bit and not everyone is in i am
uh you're gonna have mismatches like uh
let's say the match that i previously
commentated between alexandra and greg
shahadi of course
greg the heavy favorite on paper going
into that match
and that's why they had a handicap in
place to to make that more fair
now in this matchup i don't think any
handicap is necessary for an
entertaining match robert but
i do think that if cantee is gonna have
his chances
um i think it probably will need to come
uh as strange as it sounds in the blitz
portions we
we know levy to be just quite quite
dangerous in bullet and
i don't see james stacking up to him in
the bullet portion so
strange as it sounds i think his chances
are actually in the blitz robert
yeah one of the things i like most about
james is that his username is gm canty
and he's striving
to become the best title in chess and i
was looking up his
ratings on chess.com his blitz rating in
the 2500s his bullet rating actually in
the 2600s but as you said levy
he's been known to play a great bullet
game or two his ratings are through the
roof
and that's going to be a tough matchup
for james but before we even get to
that matchup we will have the arena king
season six
starting tomorrow and i'm on you gonna
take part in this
yeah this is exciting like uh it's nice
to have arena kings back
i think there is gonna be more hype than
ever for this season because there's
more people streaming than ever for this
season and that's
you know one of the requirements to to
win prizes in arena kings is you have to
be streaming and
we know how many people have picked up
streaming lately and how many people
blown up uh
in the streaming sphere so um it's gonna
be pretty exciting i know that eric and
i are probably
gonna swap in uh swap out for different
uh different editions of uh arena kings
but
i'll definitely get some uh get some
goes in i think whoever is doing better
in the season
will let them ride it out that makes
sense well i look forward to seeing you
not just
commentating alongside you but against
you in the arena kings i
definitely plan on taking part as well
and amman
you know it's about that time huh we
have just a couple minutes before the
games begin
the players settling in there looks like
lawrence is laughing about something
seems typical for him i don't know
i mean the five minute portion it's a
long segment there with 75 total minutes
they do get a break about halfway
through
the players get a few minutes to relax
but i really feel like
with two players who are quite emotional
in nature
that whoever gets out to the hot start
that could be the person who leads from
start to finish
yeah as strange as it sounds even the
guy who wins game one
is uh is gonna be at that um you know
emotional advantage that you're gonna
really be feeling
uh feeling good um i think that early on
we're gonna get that taste of what i
mentioned about
stubbornness you know if if there's an
opening disaster in game one
are we going to see that correct it for
the second time that that these guys
play white and black
the exact same colors or uh are we gonna
see maybe just a repeat of
a bad opening for one of these players
so i think it's really important early
on to see
how the opening phase goes for both
players and
whether or not either of these players
needs to adapt early on
and i think stylistically the way these
two players clash will be interesting
because
danny from the white side he's an e4
player and when people play e5 he often
plays the scotch line which
as you know from experience doesn't
always end well for him
but uh lawrence is more of a sicilian
player so that's going to allow for more
tactical battles
and i think that's to both sides benefit
they both love aggressive play
yeah and that that that just means that
we're danny has got his
mug up to the up to the camera i don't
know what that was that
lawrence on that mug or
danny by the way has got like some sort
of like bike courier
wristband on looks like he's about to
deliver me like
pizza or something that or he's about to
do some crossfit
while playing chess so uh i think that
while they're messing around they're
gonna stop very soon because the game
should start
any second now yeah and we're being told
that was actually
ryan gosling on the mug
so that's like the weirdest thing i
could have guessed would be on that mug
but you also gave the biggest compliment
to lauren's trend of his life
just thought that lawrence's face was
ryan gosling's face and
who could be upset with that compliment
yeah i i don't know i
i gave lawrence ryan gosling when he
looks a lot more like slicker
from the uk as well that is very funny
and i see the game is just starting here
danny with e4 oh no i quit
oh man robert this is this is not the
the best start for you
let's see oh well i think that this is
more of
what is okay what is this variation by
lawrence because
he put his knight on c6 which as we know
in the
french you often want to play c5 instead
he's just going for tricks
yeah this looks like um i don't know how
to how to describe it but
it looks like one of those lines you
might you might hustle a few games in
the park with
um this line definitely looks
like something lawrence has prepared and
is
sort of happy to to get against danny
here
yeah and i will say that right now danny
is left with a tough decision which is
why he hasn't moved
whether to take that pawn on bassan he
takes f6 or you could have played a move
ago or to leave it
he decides to leave it and say to
lawrence i'm not afraid
of what looks like a good central
control for you because i'm
able to counter later in the game maybe
with a c4 idea or
to move this knight away from f3 and try
to play f3 with a pawn but i actually
i don't mind black's position somehow
yeah i mean the
the nice thing about black's position is
you kind of have these knight a5
ideas and if you could ever trade light
squared bishops off i mean you're just
laughing uh if you have lawrence's
position
for sure and that bishop one d3 will
need to remain there
as amman's pointing out that knight
would love to go a5 to c4 and
potentially it does that even with the
bishop still on d3
because that dark square bishop which we
often think of as an advantage
it's not doing much of anything and
doesn't have any targets to
apply pressure on yeah and if you go for
some plan like 91
f3 i mean black doesn't really care sure
he takes the bishop on d2
but the knight on e1 is not going to be
in a great position
after you play f3 and take away its
square of return to the game
meanwhile black has a couple moves in
between he's got the knight a5 plan and
maybe try to trade light square bishops
so i really don't mind
lawrence's position right out of the
gate and let's not forget about the time
advantage
robert as danny is he's kind of in a new
position
he really is and you know if as i
reflect already it's only move ten but
as i think back of the opening
maybe taking on passant was better
because white would have had free flow
with the pieces
although so would black's pieces right
because if had the pawn
go away from the f file and the e5 pawn
black has the semi-open file things of
that nature so i think that danny is
reflecting that himself
while trying to continue this game and
that is dangerous territory because as
we both know from experience
when you're playing a game but
reflecting on the past moves you're
distracting yourself from being as
objective
as possible about the current situation
yeah that's a good point you brought
that up before the match that that danny
sometimes you know hold on holds on to
thoughts for
for too long and really just needs to
say okay the decision's done
let's continue if he wants to change
that decision well
that's why he can repeat this opening
and there's an easy uh way to to deviate
from this game in case he wants to
repeat this line
for sure and he is down quite a lot in
the clock lauren
this is a slow paced game right now
robert yeah and
well it's hard because you start with
five minutes and most of us when we play
blitz we're like three minutes
you and i when we're going at it three
minutes yes so then you think oh i'm in
a comfort zone where i have a couple
more minutes to spend
and then you start spending it too early
and your opponent builds up a big lead
it is a
two-minute time advantage for lawrence
and i kind of like his position right
now so
yeah not a good start for danny no i
wouldn't say so
right now danny is kind of uh in the
middle of two plans he wishes maybe his
bishop was on e1
so that the knight didn't have anything
to capture and f3
might look towards kicking that knight
out for real but right now after f3
i mean lord's just going to take that
bishop on d2 queen takes
and maybe he's going to go either bishop
d7 or b6 and just get that light square
bishop
i'm with you and that d3 square is one
that white would like to share with the
bishop and the knight because black's
idea is to play c5
but if white's knight were on d3 then
you take away that option or at least
make it more difficult to play and
he plays bishop e2 perhaps for this
purpose but
i don't know black can just play c5 here
and even then it's like you're getting
exactly what you want out of a french
yeah absolutely no this looks and also
the
other thing is if you go b6 and white
ever goes knight d3
it might be nice in some cases to play
bishop a6 i can't tell just so you
always have that
that trade in your back pocket wow and
lawrence wants more he's saying
i'm pushing my pawns forward because
knight d3 comes at the tempo
on that f4 pawn but he might just play
g5 and
one of these positions amman you can
tell me it feels like it's too risky in
my opinion but then sometimes it's
justified
for black yeah i i think that the way i
would view it is that the position
looked honestly good enough
that i wouldn't bother going for this
but it's not to say that this is not
a very valid way to play so it's just
more in lawrence's style
and you know for that reason i i think
it's probably better that
that he he plays this way it's he's as
you said an aggressive attacking player
he
he's got that f pawn up there he wants
to maybe have the queen join the party
on h4 or on g5 and
you know if he ever gets that queen g5
sort of knight h4
with f3 ideas uh if they start kicking
around there
this could be very good but on the other
hand danny gets to execute
the one plan that i mentioned earlier
bishop e1 and now f3 for white
is something to think about it's funny
because both of our plans somehow happen
the bishop went to e1 the knight went to
d3 and the bishop went to e2 so
both of our plans have come to fruition
here and i like
white's position because his pawn f4
look at this he's already targeting it
he can put more pressure with queen to
c1 if he wants but i wouldn't just
focus all my energy there because black
is going to play queen g5 or queen h4 as
you mentioned
so playing queen c1 feels like so it's
one trick i'm going after four pawn easy
defend
instead danny brings his knight around
is that knight coming to
h3 i i think he just wanted the bishop
on d3
and um the interesting thing about this
position is
i feel like if it gets into a
maneuvering game
that i sort of prefer white i think that
white's pieces have more room to improve
in this position like kind of higher
ceilings they honestly it's been bishop
bishop knight
that have been dancing around about five
squares for the last
seven moves so uh i think danny's pieces
can only get better
and i think one way to improve your
pieces is to take this pawn on c5
which may seem counterintuitive because
the e5 pawn drops but when you start
removing pawns from the position you
free up the remaining squares and here
i think that lawrence can play c4 to
trap that bishop to force it to capture
an f5
and as you were saying white's pieces
can improve but now i'm not really
seeing exactly how and that cemented
double pawns in the c file those in the
long run are not going to be favorable
pawns for yeah and i also was thinking
about ctag's d4 just because if danny
would have to trade
on f5 there then you sort of get that
open c file and
and in this position at least i don't
think danny is too unhappy
in the sense that there's no open c file
there's no targets for for black he's
got this a pawn to look at
danny's got the f4 pawn it looks fairly
balanced here and
as we know we have opposite bishops
which does speak to a bit more of a
balanced game but perhaps a few more
king side opportunities here for
lawrence
yeah and one of the things about these
opposite colored bishops is if white
plays a5 black can play b5 and keep that
queen side closed thanks to this bishop
on d7
white does not have a piece that can go
attack a light square on the queen side
so
i think that lawrence is relying on that
danny's just saying what
what do i have to do here i don't really
need to move right my position is very
solid
he doesn't need to move but he has less
time
so in fact he does need to move that's
the issue is when you've when you've
sort of got these closed positions or
there's not much going on time like the
the fact that you're up on time becomes
so much more important
that's very true and i meant that more
so in a
positional point of view but you're
right to look at the clock because danny
is down a minute
but what is black's idea i'm not quite
sure what is white's idea
i'm also not sure i see both sides sort
of shuffling around and then that's
where the time travel
really makes its mark because look danny
put that on a5 and on a6
but in the long run that pawn could be a
target and
it's on a light square so black can try
to attack it
so i think lawrence wants to put his
rook on f8 which frees up
either his queen or his other rook and
then maybe rook h5 takes h3
is definitely a sacrifice that i'm
looking at immediately
knight h4 and queen g6 happens and i
think danny
is really at risk right now of just
getting mated like just getting
obliterated on the king's side
if he goes for something like queen c5
or queen d6
i can see rook f8 and like bishop e8
happening and as we see
rook h5 i think this could get really
scary for danny here although cool
line is queen's things if rook b6 maybe
you could sack your queen on b6
and push that a pawn forward i haven't
calculated it at all but that is a
thematic queen sack to
have a free pawn to promote and so
that's why lauren says i don't want to
deal with any of that let me bring my
rook to f8 and now
i'm with you on this is looking very
easy for block to play
yeah and as soon as that bishop gets
defended on d7
queen g6 hits c2 which is strangely
enough it's actually a very important
pawn
um and and even just like okay knight g4
played but i think we're going to see
some kind of breakthrough
eventually like rook g5 pawn h5 and i'm
not really sure how danny intends to
meet that it seems very straightforward
yeah i have no idea i have no idea
because even rook takes g4 and
f3 i'm sure it breaks through these
rooks are just not
helping the queen side they're not
helping the king's side either no
and i guess danny's trying to rely and
look at that move knight of a very smart
move
by lawrence because knight takes g2 was
the move that i was first calculating
but i guess what lawrence want to avoid
was
white pushing the pawn to h3 and getting
a pawn to g4 keeping the position closed
here you can't do that because your
knight's under attack and you would just
lose the focus yeah this this
is uh you guys can see the eval bar uh
shimmying right down the board there uh
which is because
there there's no material imbalance he's
about to win a piece but up till now
it's about minus three minus four and he
hasn't taken anything
yeah that's when you know you're in a
tough spot when
the position is even in terms of
material but just completely hopeless in
terms of the game itself and
well i wonder if danny is going to
sacrifice this knight yeah he is so
yeah that that's a good idea considering
the time
situation and considering the board
state like even though blacks have a
piece
what next is the real question uh the h
file is definitely like rook h6
and you know g5 and and rook down is
definitely an idea
uh bishop g5 is tricky though and danny
he's looking to weasel his way in there
that was a good try but that's why
lawrence played g6
because both of his rooks covered the a7
square so
a nice last-ditch effort and the funny
thing about bishop b6 is you could also
just
kind of sit there and laugh at it
because it isn't threatening anything
anyway but as you mentioned lawrence did
have that covered laterally
which is uh uh something that paid off
for him in the end
for sure and well a one game lead for
lawrence
i wonder if we will see that french
again it looks a bit iffy to me but
lawrence clearly prepared it and moved
very quickly in the opening look at this
i mean these guys are holding back
nothing right now
yeah i mean how quick like what's more
impressive than
how quickly he played g4 it was how
quickly danny responded as if this is
something that
he sees all the time
right it's just like oh east thorn is
king side pawn at me now no big deal
play in the center that is though
strategically how we advise
people to handle things like that if
someone's attacking on a flank you don't
necessarily need to turtle up and defend
on the flank you can actually strike
back in the center
and that counter attack is a form of
defense so
the the first thing that i'm thinking is
e4 here and i'm
i'm like why is this not good if i can
cement this pawn
in any way and force white to play
either like d3 or f3
i'm feeling great right now that knight
seems like come to e5 and it's like
this feels devastating already right
because 95 now especially after 92
it's like a self made look at lawrence's
face because knight d4
covers both squares but just c5 right
and
lauren said his head in his hands just
devastated about how bad his position is
on move nine with the white people this
is the worst
worst opening i have seen in a good
minute
yeah and it's not quite over yet i think
that he has to play bishop g2
and even if he knight d3 check put his
king on f1 and you hope that you can
survive
but as long as there's no immediate
checkmate the game isn't
concluded at least not at this point
yeah the i think the issue is that
you're
i mean after queen f6 in that position
gonna like you're gonna have to play
knight f4 basically
yeah uh i don't
envy this position but lawrence he put
his head in his hands he was upset
he needs to calm himself down because
there is still plenty of game left
especially in a blitz game i know
four and a half minutes may seem like an
eternity especially to those of us who
play hyper bullet all the time
but that's not that much time to figure
out the complications
yeah and we talked about you know like
emotional turbulence and how that might
play in
i think lawrence was really feeling
himself after that last one
shoves that the jeep on up the board you
know ready to get danny in another
tricky opening and all of a sudden he's
like wait
you know i gotta i gotta maybe reign it
in a little bit you can't play
you know crazy wing attacks in every
game and have them work
as somebody who plays some of the most
suspicious openings
ever i know how it feels to play
something that's offbeat
and then you're still down a lot of time
because it backfires and
that's exactly what's happening here but
to lawrence's credit he went knight f4
he's about even on time that e4 pawn
while it is a strength
if you say play queen takes f4 white
just plays d3
opening that bishop on c1 or even d4 to
a discovered attack on that queen so the
f4 pawn remains
white's king feels safer than they did
just a couple moves ago black
i still would prefer to play from
danny's side of this position
but there's plenty of life left and you
have a lot to prove
yeah once this bishop gets out um i'm
thinking f5
and and the rooks come into the middle
the the tough thing about this position
for lawrence is that danny's moves are
not
complicated uh he he can bring the
bishop out to the most logical square
uh just put a rook on d8 and he's not
gonna be doing anything wrong
you're totally right and well it is not
complicated it seems like very
straightforward moves but you don't want
to burn clock
playing those type of moves and that's
the thing about blitz you have to
weigh playing quickly versus perfection
and i think for most players that i want
to play the best moves possible
every single turn oftentimes the move
that are coming to these
very strong players quickly are they're
often the best moves the bishop of five
is a move danny could have played
in four seconds and said he played it in
34 seconds
exactly yeah and and if that pattern
keeps up for other moves
of you know similar ease then all of a
sudden danny has like a minute and
you know a couple more couple more
simple moves so i think he's really
gonna look to
um well actually he could even trade
here and i don't think he'd be upset i
think queen e6
looks like the more maybe the nastier
move
yeah yeah but even trading i think the
end game is just crushing for
for black as well totally with you and
and this is what danny knight needs to
calculate is there some kind of queen
takes g7 check or does white have to
spend a move
with the bishop first queen takes g7
will not work though sometimes it might
here it will not
but that's what danny is now calculating
uh you know can i just move a king over
with king h8 the answer
seems to be a clear yes but then there's
bishop takes e4 as a possibility so the
tactics are really
becoming a part of this position and now
danny is going to spend more time
despite the fact that he has a much
better position
i could see this turning because of the
complications
yeah and the nice thing to keep in mind
for black is that if this pawn ever
disappears
and you're not getting mated you're
actually really happy to see that you
throw in like a bishop h3
check followed by queen c4 check operate
on the e file with the rook
and suddenly the white king is like hey
you know
we're supposed to leave that pawn there
guys that's that's part of the shelter
completely agreed so that makes king h8
even more likely of a move
because bishop takes e4 as amman was
saying bishop h3 checks the possibility
but look at this
bishop g6 played after about a minute
think still a very good move
clogging the g-file but it's one of
these moves where like
is danny going to go on the defensive
now or is he just
fending off the initial attack and then
countering himself
yeah because all you need um is to buy
just that little bit of time
and after f5 i think lawrence is just
hoping to go to an end game although
i don't think his chances are too much
better
in an end game here like queen takes f5
i think that that looks just fine
i'm wondering why bishop takes f5
because the only response the bishop
takes if i sees bishop takes e4
but i'm taking your advice of hey
actually i want that pawn off the board
so go ahead and take it yeah the thing
is bishop takes f5 is such a hard move
to make
because you just played bishop g6 right
so to go back and play the exact same
position where it's your opponent's turn
it's like uh no
not for me i'm with you it's much easier
to sit as a commentator and suggest that
move because i don't have to deal with
the
repercussion of the attack but danny
says hey iman is just being
very logical here let's go to this end
game and it's not quite a pure end game
because still many pieces on the board
but look at white's bishop on c1 that's
hardly a bishop that's a
big pawn sitting there can't get out the
d-pawn is backwards
you know would love to play move like d4
but you just lose a pawn on the spot
with on passant so
yeah this is no good danny's got a good
handle in this position but one thing
about bishop g6 which
you know does allow is a4 and previously
there was always bishop d7
to hit the rook hit that a pawn and just
always be a general nuisance on the
light squares
so a4a5 is exactly what lawrence needs
to
at least have a target on the queen side
and say look danny you know you might
you might be winning this game but at
least there's something you always have
to keep your eye on
totally good point and i like how danny
responds instantly with rook to d6
saying
i'm never going to take you on a5
because while that shatters my pawn
structure it also gives this bishop on
c1
a new lease on life that bishop if it
goes to a3 now it attacks nothing the
pawn on c5 is defended
by this pawn chain so that is what danny
is doing he's keeping that bishop on c1
in tuned by the rest of the pawn
structure
and so lawrence is just making moves at
this point but now
okay h5 that's a risky move because at
some point perhaps rook g5
will come in for now richie finds me by
bishop f6 so it seems that danny has
everything covered but you are creating
some more weaknesses
yeah if this bishop stays on c1 the
whole game i mean let's be clear it's
it's going to be a loss for lawrence
because the pawns on the queen side keep
it locked out the bishop a3 diagonal
doesn't go anywhere
and that pawn on e4 you and i were
talking about that move
was it like move six or seven like ages
ago like oh that looks like a good one
and now it's actually
keeping white completely locked down
here in quarantine if you will
for sure there's really very little that
white can do here besides shuffle
so that begs the question what is black
going to do to win this game because the
position
looks great it is great but how do we
actually end this game decisively
i'm looking at bishop f4 as a nice move
to control g5
hit d2 just kind of get on a nicer
square bishop f6
uh hits the h4 pawn but i i like bishop
f4 for some reason just
just hitting that d2 pawn and taking
control of some some squares there
the one thing about bishop f4 is white
gets this d4 type of move
as now ambassador is met by hanging
bishop on f4 so even though white has to
give up on in those
sequences maybe that's worth it to at
least trade off your worst piece and
that's
an interesting note i think for our
audience is that isn't the material more
important
or is it the quality of our pieces yep
and the
quality of white species has certainly
been in question for the
majority of this game bishop takes c3 is
let's say it's on the cards but it looks
like lawrence is he does some bishop h5
uh move he wants to throw in now it
doesn't work yeah it's just a free
just a pawn yeah and danny takes it he
has 45 seconds plenty of time left on
his talk
actually he's really played a nice game
keeping lawrence
stuck in the box and then taking
material when it was offered to him and
lawrence i don't think saw that coming
he's clearly been frustrated with his
position and danny should be able to
even the score
as this game uh nears its conclusion yep
yeah i don't see a good way to continue
here maybe he's gonna go rook b7 or rook
a6 to try to
prevent black from taking on d2
ah it was king f1 so bishop d2 there's
bishop b2 check
and something that king on f6 isn't
quite so safe
check me yeah
that's uh that's a funny mate if you
move the gang rook takes g6 as robert's
pointing out and
king has nowhere to go bishop back to e5
are we going to see d4
we're going to get another game that's
another mate on e7
oh no d4 is a very good move he plays d3
so what it's a oh it's one of those
moves where obviously your plans bishop
to g5
check but he chose the less forcing
option and d3 clearly was not the right
move and we can see with the
evaluation bar going back down in
black's favor
because look at danny he shuts that
bishop down from c1 that's what he's
been going against the entire game
and now the d-pawn can't move because
the bish 1d1 is hanging behind it
no great great point and now i'm really
concerned for lawrence's position
after just rook d3 and brook d1
yeah rook d1 just scoops off two bishops
for the rook and there might actually be
a checkmate right the king goes to g2
pawn f3 would be checkmate so he goes to
e2 instead
nice game yeah this has been a really
nice game from uh
from danny here and and if king d2 there
was bishop f4 check
which is why he's gone he's gone to e3
is bishop for checkmate actually so so
many weird mates in this game
yeah oh man these bishops are gonna
wreak havoc here rook b2
danny i think has got this game under
control
yeah i'm not too worried about his
ability to win this one
the bishop on d4 i think you can call
that a great piece
we'll go with great for now
and now the pawn's just rolling yeah
bishops cover way too many squares here
and
just a great game the funny thing about
the the final position is
you don't even have stalemate tricks
because you have the d1 square
yeah it's checkmated one threatened and
the king's just locked in but
as you said that's very important to
point out though because it's easy to
think oh i'll just push my pawn go for
checkmate
and then you don't realize your opponent
just sacrifices the rooks and makes a
stalemate but wasn't available there and
hey we have this french again yeah i
think already we've seen the first
adaptation as danny has gone for a
quicker
e5 than last time so he didn't let the
knight
get to f6 first instead he played e5
preemptively and
it was met with f6 uh by lawrence and he
puts his quinceanera i see
the evaluation bar went down in black's
favor which means that knight takes d4
and then e5 is attacked
here and i would not have seen that
immediately myself
but when i see the evaluation bar going
down there must be some tactic otherwise
it doesn't make sense that black would
be so favored here
yeah and knight takes knight takes e5
queen takes e5 is just met by brook
e8 which backs up uh robert's tactic
there
and it's just one of those situations
where you're trying to do a little too
much in the opening developing the queen
when you know you got that tender pawn
and the way that black's opening works
with that knight c6
is they generally don't go for c5 the
the moves for black are usually
revolving around some sort of e5
break so tactically black should be on
the lookout
for tactics revolving around the e5
break in general a little bit more than
c5 so that was an option there for
lawrence he doesn't see it plays queen
d6
he wants to play e5 a little bit more
organically it looks like
and it's impossible to blame somebody
for not finding that and i'm serious the
only reason i saw it was
i quickly looked and i saw that the
evaluation bar plummeted and i was like
okay that means there's a tactic
and it's such a simple position we're
gonna move eight so what else could
there be
besides a night sacrifice just to break
open the position so
i you know can't fault either of the
players for overlooking that that's one
of the things where once you
realize it's possible you're like oh
okay never again but to even
think about it as being a possibility is
something that you really have to train
yourself
uh to master absolutely um we've seen
asics so lawrence has actually taken a
much slower approach than
the eval bar would would like him to uh
but
also bishop d7 bishop e8 bishop h5
as long as that might take is a very
common maneuver you might look at the e5
break and say well that's not happening
what am i going to do with this light
square bishop that's usually the
maneuver either to put it on g6
or more commonly h5 where it's going to
pin that knight and then the d4
pawn really becomes tender completely
agreed
and speaking of tender d4 pawn now the
bishop's on a5 at some point you have to
watch out for bishop to b6
putting another attacker right there in
the center and
i like your idea with bishop b7 first i
don't think you have to rush this bishop
to b6 decision
because that would later invite knight
a4 type of stuff so i would play bishop
d7
you can either put your rook or your
bishop on e8 depending on how white
responds
and i think that lawrence considering uh
you know
the state of this position he should be
perfectly happy
yeah and bishop d7 even if you don't go
for bishop e8 bishop h5
i think the bishop just needs to go
there anyway you're not going to play b6
in this position with your bishop on a5
uh b5 doesn't look any better so i think
your bishop just needs to go to d7
if not just to connect the rooks and he
plays bishop to b6 he
does the immediate pressure on the d4
pawn
and i guess white's only move to defend
his bishop e3
at this point not exactly move you want
to play because the semi-open e file was
yours for the taking
now you're blocking your own queen's
access along the line
yeah and now i guess bishop d7 makes
sense as well i think white's gonna get
you know the rooks look pretty good on
sort of e1 d1
but i think i think bishop e8 bishop h5
is something to really
uh worry about or something that you
need an answer to simply
he goes knight g4 because instead of the
slower which i i liked your plan a lot
with bishop d78 he says rook takes f3
is a big threat trying to checkmate you
over there on h2
and it's not just the uh sacrificing
exchange there's also a d4 pawn hanging
because the knight is really needed
on f3 to defend the king side so by
process of elimination i'd say g3
is the move that white has to play in
which case your eventual
bishop getting involved in light squares
is going to be even more powerful
as g3 makes the remaining light squares
weaker yep
no that's well said g3 um basically if
you go h3
if lawrence wanted to he could still
sack on f3
white would take on g4 and then he'd
probably just bring the rook back
somewhere and say okay your d-pawn is
weaker as a result and not so sure that
that pawn on on g4 is going to be a good
thing
exactly because that semi-open h5 would
be good if white had a rook there but
when the king's over there that could
cause some problems
and as you point out the d4 pawn remains
a target for lawrence to pile up on so
i mean g there's really not a move you
want to play here for white so i could
understand
why danny would go h3 just to avoid
weakening the light squares
but it does come with the cost of that
d4 pawn becoming pretty proud what about
bishop takes h7 like because he's
spending time that has to be the
move he's considering here other than
pawn moves in front of the king
well issue h7 uh the point is that if
king takes h7 knight g5 check
you win that knight back on g4 i kind of
like that i mean i really didn't
put much stock into it at first i wasn't
thinking along those lines but
that's on me that's me overlooking a
tactic that
could be good he does it so
king h8 is definitely what i was gonna
say
regardless of what happens i think
that's the move he was going to play
but i think maybe we needed a more
energetic response from lawrence like
taking that bishop allowing queen g4 and
just trying like e5 queen h5 bishop f5
something like that
i'm with you that's like in the style of
the french where you get that bishop out
you feel good about your position here
queen h5 probably just lands checkmate
in a couple moves because your king's
stuck in the corner here ooh that's bad
knight f7
and then after check you have bishop
takes h6 if he tries to sneak that
knight into block i think
danny is is going to get lawrence here
i'm trying to
try to find like the best way to
continue
playing here and i'm kind of struggling
because there's checkmate on e8 as well
right like if rook f6
you play bishop g6 check and then just
check on h7 with your queen check on h8
with your queen and then
mate on e8 in the end i know it's may be
hard to visualize for some more audience
but it's a very
forcing sequence so lawrence yeah he's
pretty much out of options here
and that's a pretty funny kind of
checkmate black has you know
six seven pieces around the king and the
white's queen is just waltzing in like
yeah that's uh never fun when you have
that especially when you're
up more material than lawrence is
currently up because he's up a piece
right now
for one pawn and yeah you're up like
three pieces you're like oh i'm winning
oh this is happening yeah
well if anyone had trouble visualizing
hopefully danny is going to be able to
show you exactly what robert meant
yep this is the exact checkmate and he's
gonna allow it yeah
see there that's how you know danny and
i unfortunately have becoming more in
sync with one another
well actually maybe this is fortunate
for him and unfortunate for me where
he is now finding these direct
checkmates and
you know he's doing as i said and the
match actually
has come to a pause because in the i'm
not a gm speech championship there is a
break for the players midway through
the time segments so with that in mind
any final thoughts on the first three
games that we've seen here before we had
a break
well what we've seen uh because we've
only seen three games we've only seen
the white
pieces um for danny twice so lawrence
hasn't had his second game with white
and what we've seen is the french every
time
and uh what i'm seeing from these
positions so far is that
i'm actually liking them for for
lawrence the way that they're
they're trending i think that he has a
lot of opportunities that he can
capitalize on
in general uh we haven't necessarily
seen them danny uh
played a great good game this time uh
but he did give up some tactical shots
on the way
in a break i can see lawrence take
taking a look at these games and being
like
i'm gonna keep playing this opening i'm
not unhappy with the evals the positions
that i'm getting
against danny i mean if you're getting
these types of positions with the french
robert
i think you have to keep playing it um
the way the match is going so far
i'm with you i feel like the first two
games the results were fair both players
dominated the games they won and this
third game was more of a toss-up where
danny
uncorked a tactic because lawrence
himself was the one who went for
adventurous
uh opportunities so what with that we'll
take a quick break we will return
with more from this i'm not a gm speed
chess championship brought to you by
chess.com
and we return with more action from the
i'm not a gm speeches championship
i'm on danny wrench the beloved
chess.com
chief chess officer uh commentator just
personal extraordinaire he is out to a
2-1 lead
over lawrence trent himself a very
famous well-known commentator so
danny has to feel happy thus far but you
and i were talking during the break
for lawrence you don't think he should
be too upset about his play either
no i mean let's first give credit where
credit's due not only did uh
danny win the most recent game before
the break but he also had what i would
say is
maybe the most dominating game that
we've seen so far in the match
which was game two with those two
bishops and the way he just punished
lawrence's maybe over aggressive opening
with the white pieces so we're
interested to see
what lawrence comes up with with the
white pieces we know he's going to
adjust he's not going to repeat
that line exactly but yeah and if you're
in lawrence's camp i don't think you're
too unhappy the score is two to one
you're only down a game you haven't even
had the white pieces twice yet
and uh i think that both games with the
french
although he's one-on-one with it i think
he can be happy with the positions he's
getting and if he uses that break
even to just check a few computer
evaluations or maybe review his lines
there
i think he'll be happy with what he
finds yeah i'm with you there partner
and i
do think that game two was one where
lawrence is not going to be repeating
that g4 g5 is sort of i'm hyper
aggressive but it backfires in
two moves because danny put his pawn e4
his knight on e5 and everything started
looking terrible
for lawrence who had the white pieces in
that game so i think we'll see something
different from him maybe something
more initially solid before storming for
an attack but
hey we have liftoff and c4 once again is
played
yep so i think he's generally okay with
g4
but he's really i mean he's checked this
let's let's be clear
this this has to be different than last
time and there we go he's got d3 he's
checked it and he says look
this is still playable i trust myself
here what do you make what's your
initial take on
d3 you know he's clearly prepped this in
the break is this
something that you're feeling confident
about
well lawrence must have played this
before and the reason i say that is
because danny is coming and playing
really quickly in response to this
obscure opening so
he must have seen lawrence's database of
games said this is something he might
play against me
and thus i feel ready to handle it but
it's just such a weird dynamic where it
feels like black is the one who has all
the immediate pressure look at this pawn
on d3
you can't play bishop g2 like you want
to because then you drop the d3 pawn
immediately so
i had this feeling that this should be
pretty good for black
from both a an objective point of view
but also just a strategic point of view
it seems easier to my eyes for black to
play
yep yep i'm i'm with you there because
well we might even see just like queen
d7 or something from
from black i'm not sure how scary queen
b7 is supposed to be and we do see queen
d7
um if white can sort of sneak in a bunch
of moves in a row like he gets his
knight to g3
and then plays bishop e2 i could believe
some light square control with h4h5
coming and bishop on g6 but
as we see he's got to play rook d1 he's
got to defend his pawn on d3 before he
can do that stuff
it just feels like if you can get
everything you want
it's a nice structure but um i can't see
that happening in an easy way here
yeah i think that you know you would
ideally be able to capture this pawn on
b7 you can't do that because rook b8 is
a very straightforward response winning
the bishop behind the queen on b2 that's
why lawrence edward brooke to d1 and
yeah he has the d3 pawn defended for the
moment
and one of the big questions that danny
is trying to ponder here is
should he castle queenside that gets the
king out of the center connects the
rooks but perhaps on the
queen side the king is in danger but i
think on the king side it's also going
to be in danger so he says hey let's do
this
yep he castles along at adds even more
pressure
immediately to that d-pawn now i don't
know if it's actually something that can
be captured
but at least you know it needs
consideration and
lawrence gives it about two seconds of
consideration and says
uh you can't take it and if you really
want to you can calculate it
well i think one of the big problems is
if you are going to take this pawn on d3
you need to have the move e5 to e4
as a follow-up to defend the bishop on
that square but e4 is not a possibility
with the bishop hanging on g7 behind the
pawn so that's why
danny does not take it instead plays
bishop to g4 which threatens bishop
f3 for example not only does it pin the
knight but can you plant the bishop
there
kick the rook out of the corner so i
mentioned how black's king might not be
saved but amman is white's king really
going to be any safer here
yeah well at this point i think it's
fair to say
that um white's not playing on castling
now he could of course go
some sort of bishop g2 thing but yeah
rook g1 feels much more natural
he's using one rook to defend d3 the
other rook to operate on the g-file
and he's saying look although there's an
open d file here otherwise the position
is
it's not too open like the king doesn't
have diagonals to worry about this a5 e1
can't see black taking advantage of that
so actually bishop takes e2 king takes
e2 if that were to happen i think
lawrence's king is just fine in the
center of the board
completely agreed and one thing that
white needs to figure out because
there's a bishop on g2 a queen on b3
you want to kick that knight out of c6
and one way that you would try to do
that is playing d4 but not with that
king on e1
absolutely not right d4 would be way too
risky blowing open the center when your
king is on e1
bishop takes e2 for instance so i think
that
lawrence is going to need to figure out
a way to actually increase his attack
but as you're pointing out his king
seems all right here on e1
yeah and if danny basically gets the
move um
f4 in even if it loses a pawn or
something
we know at this moment that lawrence's
king is not going to the left
or the right it's stuck in the middle so
i think if you just
open the position generally speaking
definitely a good thing for for danny
for sure and he brings that rook to e8
saying f4 becomes even more powerful
you're certainly not taking enough for
that
situation because the rook opens up but
the downside of playing f4 is that the
e4 square
becomes whites for the taking and while
the initial
concrete attack is more valuable to
black in the long run if you can fend
off the attack
then put a bishop or knight eventually
on e4 that would be good news
for lawrence yeah we see f3 which is
definitely not my first take on the
position but
you sort of see what he wants to do he
wants to free the
the knight on e2 to move if necessary
like
knight c3 um he goes bishop c3 to follow
up so
at some point he might just go like e4
solidify
like that that bishop on d5
and and try to play that position i'm
trying to see what other intentions you
might have with f3
he's i guess he wants to get rook b1 in
and if
the pawn we're not in f3 right now you
put that palm back in f2 there could be
something bishop takes e2 and knight d4
check i know that may be difficult for
our audience but that was one of the
ideas potentially though
that knight can't really move i
mentioned this earlier that is pretty
stuck on c6
so i don't think that would have worked
and now the e3 pawn is a target so i
actually like how this is
turning for danny yeah and in response
to rook b1
uh i think just b6 is all like is that
all that uh that black has to to guard
that pawn because
if so i feel like i would be throwing
rook b1 in yeah b6 is a really scary
move to have to play but you're right
that's
what the response would have been and
i'm with you because
now the king's in f2 you still have rook
to b1 as an
option but i don't really like the look
of this king sitting on f2 for example
f4
and maybe queen h3 at some point can be
really scary for this king on f2
yeah and and i'm wondering why like okay
so how does black meet rook be one in a
good way
um i see the eval bar definitely
favoring black and
it looks like one of those positions
that that should favor him but after
rook b1
like b6 queen a4 like i start to get
pretty
pretty concerned with uh black's
position and that's exactly why danny
went bishop f7 saying well now you play
rook b1
i will play b6 but you don't have time
to use amman's plan of queen to
b5 and queen a4 and get in on those
light squares because a bishop trait is
being offered on d5 so
i'm with you about it felt like this was
just a move too slow for lawrence to pry
open the queen side
yeah because bishop h6 i mean although
it threatens e3
that's not a check so you could play
rook b1 and then
king f2 or and then queen a4 and then
king f2 there's a lot of
maybe in between moves that could have
been thrown in there and
you always want to think about the
weaknesses you may create or you know
what
kind of tempo you may gain and here i
think white should play
e4 himself and say let me keep that
bishop on d5 you mentioned that idea
the thing i don't really love about is
once say this pawn moves away from f5
that queen can jump into h3 and that's
just king on f2
that king is not happy to be there yeah
and
if you take with the f pawn ever you're
just asking for it not only is the e3
square
guarded by h3 as well the f files just
opened up on your king so
um very very scary actually and i know
this is kind of weird but after e4
i'm also a little concerned about
strangely move like bishop f8 and like
maybe coming to c5
that's another good point because maybe
you can even clog the b-file with the
bishop if
white allows it and just to safeguard
this king on c8 so
multiple options here for danny he
is a little bit ahead on the clock but i
think that honestly white's position
somehow is easier to play because either
you're getting checkmated
or the situation the center is so
clumped in there that i think it
actually helps white play a little more
quickly and black
has to figure out what's going on yeah
definitely
definitely and the big decision because
if you take on e4 here d takes e4 and
suddenly
that d file is opened up right on your
queen you have to
you have to make the right decision
whether that's something you want to
allow or not because it's very committal
it can't go back
yeah i mean i really want to get my
queen to h3 but i recognize that there
are some tactical difficulties
in these variations so danny trying to
figure it out he is now
down quite a bit of time and i'm looking
at him with his gaming goggles
on he's trying to uh work through this
and you pick queen e7 to head over to h4
and maybe to c5 as you mentioned uh that
f8 a3 diagram could be useful for a
check
on c5 at some point yeah and and
danny really looks like um some sort of
like
40 year old cyberpunk character right
now
which is an interesting look he's going
for yeah he also looks like he could be
in pokemon with that glove
absolutely he he looks like he was like
the first trainer
oh my gosh he would have loved to hear
you say that so
too bad he's playing and not joining us
in the call but
yeah he does bring his queen to c5 this
king is going to slide over to
okay it goes to g2 just to give you e2
to h1 and the thing is once
white solves the king like once a king
gets to g2
slash h1 i mean there's nothing to worry
about there
now it's like wait a minute i'm kind of
safe let's full send that attack we were
talking about and rook b1 yeah he's
going right for it
and queen this is an idea that amman was
mentioning
10 moves ago or so and now it's finally
happening exactly your point that the
light squares are really vulnerable
that bishop on d5 somehow has survived
way too long
i know and this bishop on g6 and h6
both look kind of unimpressive at the
moment i think you have to take the
bishop on d5 with the rook
i was i was thinking about that this
looks like bishop takes a5
and queen c6 is in the air rook b5 in
the air
oh gosh but which one right that's the
he takes it yeah i feel like rook b5 and
rook takes a5 was the way to go
okay so if you take on a5 the pawn
captures black's pawn structure looks
bad
but the king can at least escape so yep
he does take it
he could have thrown a bishop b7 check
first that would have won an exchange
oh yep that's oh that would have been
cool
but now look at danny's room five yep oh
that works coming to b2
king h3 no he goes to h1 wait why did he
give the a pawn he could have
oh there's a discovered check i guess so
he goes like this we give him all his
pawns
yeah well strangely enough that king
might run like all the way to h3 it's
kind of hilarious
wait that actually might be a good idea
it's not insane no it actually looks
really good with the
g5 definitely to g5
yeah kg5 king h4 was a serious idea
yeah he's hopped up on getting that rook
to b2 but
white's not gonna let that happen so
easily no
and king h6 a little bit too late to get
the king to h3 perhaps but he can still
go for it
yep the problem is that rook on c8 can't
get involved
right you'd have to go rook c5 rook c to
a5 and then try to do something like
that oh there's a bit of panic here from
from lawrence
he can't defend that a pawn in a good
way king g5 let's go kg5 is actually
begging to be played at this point to
get rid of the pin take that i'll take
it in rock a6 yeah
and now he's taking a6 anyway yeah yeah
he can't danny's tandy wants that king
back like
really badly wait now obstacle bishops
oh you didn't take the pawn
and it's the wrong color h-pawn just for
the record yeah i have to say that
you know make sure everybody notices
it's the wrong color h pawn for both
guys
unfortunately it's not going to matter
for danny i don't think so
this is going to be bishop back to e4
and f6 or just bring that king
yeah here comes the king to help usher
the pawn to the other side
that should promote relatively soon yeah
bishop f2 at least try
yeah tough tough
yeah now look at the dominance white's
up three pawns and all the pieces are
doing well here yeah and and lawrence is
keeping everything protected by
something
and with f7 and c7 being threats i don't
think we're going to see
a brick g8 so you can promote next and
there we go we see a promotion
no stalemates no tricks and that's an
even match
wow and 2-2 just like that lawrence it i
felt like he really sees the opportunity
as soon as
the king got to g2 you could feel like
you know lauren's kind of sitting up in
the chair
being like wait a minute my king's safe
now danny you're dead on the queen side
you know that was a obviously none of
these games are going to be perfect
no matter who's playing in a blitz
competition there are going to be some
mistakes but that was a pretty
well initiated attack by lawrence just
the what we saw stemming from the
opening
keeping up the pressure and it was very
difficult for danny to fend off the
ensuing pressure
yeah and we see in this game
lawrence has gone for the french again
and he's even changed
some of his lines he's just gone wait a
minute why don't i go bishop d6 and just
e5
that's the way i think this line was
intended to be played
and every time i see this this line uh
robert i'm just like why is danny
playing this none of these positions
look good at all
no this black's already castled you
don't even have an isolated pawn which
would usually be the drawback of playing
an e5 type of move
so right black's pawn structure healthy
the pieces are active and coordinated
and white isn't doing badly and probably
will castle queen side i guess
but it takes a bit of time yeah i mean
usually this pawn on c6
you take it and you just put it on f7
and that's like a position that maybe is
playable for black
put that on c6 you got a great pawn
chain you got the open f file
i think you're just uh sailing here with
the black
knight e4 this is really good for black
i completely agree because you know
bishop takes e4
black will get an isolated pawn on e4
once you recapture
but keep those queens on the board play
for the initiative here
blackwell both bishops really active the
rook on fade is staring at f2 no this is
not how you want your opening to go from
the white side of a french
yeah this is just crazy like bishop e3
almost looks like it has to be played if
you don't take that knight
and then queen g6 just
attack g2 i don't see too many good ways
to defend it if you castle you're
castling right into bishop takes h3
no and if you play rook g1 there's like
bishop h2
to kick that rock oh that's that's cruel
that's cool yeah this is this is no fun
and you can also tell by danny's clock
usage that he's not enjoying his
position at all
this is unacceptable like i don't think
you can be playing
e4 e6 and letting this happen against
what is basically just a sideline
yes and it's honestly black's life is
too easy here just look at this you want
bishop g5
just to go back to e3 you should have
played bishop e3 right away
and then you wouldn't have all these
difficulties and it's interesting
because
black isn't like completely winning yet
but no every single aspect of this
position is favorable for black you've
already castles
you have a semi-open file that you can
work with but the semi-open d-file
you're already slow to get there and
it's a pawn chain all well defended so
the
minor pieces better for black more
active nah
no fun no fun queen g6 rook e8
is gonna happen um if i'm white here i
think that i
like i just want to castle um
i want to castle queen side because i'm
i'm honestly
i'm too scared to castle king's side
let's put put it that way
i think you're right to be skeptical
there might be like a very quick mate
and castle kingston i don't even think
bishop takes h3 right away
yeah i'm sure it's at least fine
if not winning right so you have to end
up casting queen side but there might be
knight takes f2 tactics which is why
uh not lauren so danny is currently
thinking here because
castle queen side you move your king
away from the defense of the pawn knight
takes f2
when the bishop moves away from f5 the
rook on f8 will then
be opened up to that f2 square so i
believe that tactic will work out in
black's favor
yeah yeah so even if long castle's here
knight f2 right away is that what you're
saying
yes yeah that that is probably what
danny's going through right now
um at i would say a slower pace than we
are which is why
the clock is ticking and ticking he
doesn't want to castle king's side
looks too scary and he's like well i
gotta go queen side and then he's
evaluating he's like wait a minute
knight f2
and i'm i'm probably in trouble there
which is why he landed on rook f1
you know that's a very difficult move to
play psychologically because
it's you know obviously now you have to
castle queen side because you can't
castle king such a movie of rook
and the sole purpose of the move is to
defend the pawn which is what you need
but then he's saying well
actually what's lawrence's response here
how is he going to increase
his potential in the position take
advantage of the fact that i haven't
casted yet because casting queenside is
happening next
and i'm not quite sure how black fully
stops it and he played c5 wow
yeah i think he wants to go for c4 try
to force that light squared bishop off
the board
but rook f1 is one of those moves that
never feels good to play when you
haven't castled at least one
in the other direction because it's
almost the move that you play
when you try to castle as a kid and you
accidentally touch your rook first
and then arbiter comes by and says sorry
you gotta move your rook and you're like
oh man i gotta play rook f1
you know what's happened to the best of
us so yep speaking from experience over
here
yep been there and look at that bishop
takes c5 not
pieces not defended well look at
lawrence he did not see that coming at
all
he's like what am i doing my position
was perfect and now i'm
pushed upon and then it was captured
immediately
yeah and what a weird tac like you just
don't see that in chess too often
that some one guy really has the upper
hand the the other side isn't castled
you just kind of expand the the pawns in
the center and all of a sudden
one just gets picked off that's such a
weird feeling yeah i think it
stems from playing with like your
intuition rather than with
your thought and it's not to be overly
critical of lawrence but c5
is a good move if not for the fact that
your bishop on f5 was not well defense
you always want to look for loose pieces
danny was able to steal the pawn on c5
bring the bishop right back
but this isn't over right bishop f4
stops away from castling
and he plays b5 it also makes casting a
little bit harder because there's a
potential attack
but i think that lawrence despite
blundering upon there
he still has plenty of opportunity to
create a legitimate attack
but i think we've talked about this
before is that um
you were mentioning to me in the break
that the previous bishop h7 that he sort
of missed in the in the game where he
got checkmated very quickly
after he missed the tactic he sort of
responded very quickly and it's
sometimes a bit of an ego thing you
don't want to tell your opponent that
you missed something it's like oh yeah
that was part of my plan and
i saw that move and here he kind of got
his pocket picked
on c5 and i loved your bishop f4 move
that would have been the follow-up
if you just spent a little bit of time
and said okay let me make the best of
this next position
i blundered upon but hey bishop f4 i'm
still in this game allowing danny to
castle here
he just kind of chucked b5 out as a as a
response to losing
a pawn and i don't think it was the the
best he could do and now he's just
suffering opposite bishops
we might see the same type of game that
lawrence just won but now it's danny's
turn
and we were talking about a position
just like this but with a black pawn
f7 right you give essentially the equal
material and you play against an
isolated pawn
now white's also up a pawn and the king
on b1 is perfectly safe
it's not very easy to play a5 and then
b4 because white can probably just pick
off this b5 pawn at some point so
lawrence is grasping at straws to create
an attack here and you're right i think
it is
not to specifically say that lawrence is
the sole person who
uh falls victim to this but we all do
when we play something we're like oh we
overlooked it let me just make a quick
response so
my opponent doesn't think that i'm a
fool and i'm blundering no i'm gonna do
something quick so
it seems like wait what was what was he
thinking what's he planning here
but in reality no this was another
blunder and as you said a quick
follow-up
that should have uh been a position
where lord said you know it's not
so bad for me despite the fact that i
did make a big mistake
yeah not at all and the position we have
here is going to be one where
lawrence is going to put pressure on the
clock that's that's his win condition
i think uh is the best way to put it um
h4 played i think danny's looking for h5
positionally speaking i would be really
interested in g3 and then
f4 uh but h5 is the you know aggressive
attacking way to finish things off
yeah and at some point knight takes d3
can be a consideration
but you don't really want to keep
yourself with an isolated pawn on d5 and
it's knight blockading it which is why
he did play
bishop e5 here perhaps he'll take this
knight on d4 if you if white allows it
so if i'm danny i i probably wouldn't
allow it and that's why i played knight
f3
and h5 yeah gotta be h5 i think he's
just going to continue
yeah because if you move the g pawn you
lose the h7 pawn then d5
falls after that this is no fun
yeah and this king on b1 with this pawn
a3 b2 c3 setup
so safe um i mean do you play like
crazy enough a5 here and just b4
you probably have to out of just sheer
desperation you go for that because
white's king sitting safe and sound the
king on g8 now not exactly
very safe over there at some point you
can swing over the h file
maybe now but he didn't just go rookie
one so it's clear that he's not cause
this is looking slow uh by danny rookie
one rookie two i feel like
the b4 move is happening here
like yeah right now we have we haven't
been paying attention to the clock
danny only has 18 seconds left and
that's why he's moving quickly look at
this knight c6 idea
hitting the rook on b8 trying to take on
b4 with the knight and if black plays b3
at least the queen side is
closed down from the rook's infiltration
yep no knight c6 is is important i think
danny was
counting on this one so lawrence is
going to go b3 and now
maybe brooke c8 rookie e8 both look wait
there's reasonable also bishop f4
hitting the queen and the knight on c6
is not defending wow what a what a
discovered attack there
yeah there's knight e7 in response oh
that's it but that that has to be what
what you want to see because you can
take on d2 take on d3 take on f2 there
i mean this could get really wild with
complications
right all the pieces and there it is
bishop f4 97 chat probably the only move
he plays
yeah wait you just dropped the piece i
don't think he realized it was hit
and i i simply don't think he noticed
that
and if rook c6 is ideal rook h1 somehow
to
go i think i think that is the i mean
queen f6
seems to did he not notice it either
well maybe sing the oh 97
queen takes and then queen d4 oh that's
so nice
oh he what oh took back okay your move
queen d4 is good though
for sure okay so what do we have here
opposite bishops i mean my goodness
oh my gosh
daddy oh that's
heartbreaking stuff
wow oh my goodness
uh there were tactics all over the place
and
yeah that was actually an insanely
tactical
game like even missing some of the
pieces uh that were hanging
it created even more tactics for the
next move right
wow that that was
i don't really have anything more to say
so we have a new game
where instead of playing for g4 and all
this stuff it seems like we have a more
closed positional battle
and i don't know who that favors at
least
you know we don't have to worry about
these kind of crazy attacks just yet
but i can't get over that i think it
favors us in the commentary booth
because we can just calm down a little
bit after that last blunder
that that was yeah that was bad so yeah
and
you could tell danny is he's still
thinking about that
this is one of those moments where the
you know like the the camera pans into
danny's mind and the screen blurs a
little bit and
he's just flashbacks to blundering the
rook on e7 so he's really got to focus
up here and
get a good game in because actually
lawrence has been on a roll ever since
the break
he's come back he's won two games in a
row and and he's been he's been looking
sharp that
that game clock is counting down and
there's only going to be so many
games that you can get in in the
five-minute portion and
you're totally right that denny does
need to collect himself here because
right now his position is perfectly good
right he is the one who is
trying to make inroads on his opponent's
king the light squares
for white over there and that's why i
played f5 he's
saying 96 okay your knight's in there
but i'm collapsing your center and if e4
can be chopped down then d5 becomes a
weakness then 96 and over
f7 just move my rook out of the way the
bishop is well defended on c5
so ultimately danny moving quickly and
it's turning out okay for him
in the current position but he needs to
take a breath because
he is just about level in this match
he's down
one point but it's because of just
blunders from both sides in that
previous game
yeah i i think danny needs to focus up
here and not let the score run up too
much in his opponent's favor because i
love his position
um take on e4 uh seems seems extremely
reasonable and
i'm honestly even thinking about those
lines where you give up your bishop for
this knight on d4
and just go like knight g6 bring a rope
to e8 it just seems really
really easy to play that's like one
option i like that plan
because they're often positions where
your opponent has a bishop and you have
a knight
and we hear oh the bishop is so strong
because it
plays on both sides of the board but
there's no clear target like you look at
the
pawn structure all these pawns are in
dark squares but the base pawn
c7 and g7 is immune to a bishop's attack
from e3 or even if it gets to d4 so
it seems like a good strategy for black
to take on before at some point to take
on d4 as you said
and maybe maybe leave the tension maybe
you take on d4 and just play knight g6
and say maybe i'll play f4 for black if
you're not careful or i'll just take on
e4 i like
leaving more pieces right in the
position the tension
alive yeah so i think the biggest choice
is whether he includes
fe or not because i i think that okay he
goes knight g6
uh important to note that knight e6
isn't really possible at the moment
because the bishop is hanging
so i think he might be planning for a
bishop takes d4
type of position but he says look it's
pinned for the moment
if you want to go knight c2 be my guess
the e5 square is mine
and i'm just gonna slowly you know bring
the rook into e8 if this queen ever
moves really watch out for queen g4
uh by black and you know if you get
queen g4 you hit the e pawn got knight
h4 coming in
already looks pretty scary so lawrence
has gotta really watch for that g4
square and g4 and if the queen moves say
to e2 then the a4 square
also is one that that queen could jump
to so the queen on d1 doing an important
job
knight e5 of course how should we play
your knights under attack
bring that into the center here
this looks great for danny
yep here we go
he might sneak that rook up somewhere
like rook f4
rook f5 yeah rook of four rook five
looks reasonable because especially on
f4 if you capture that the g
pawn takes and then watch out for like a
king f3 rook g1 from white
turning the tables on black's king so
rookie four's a really good move i
wouldn't be surprised if the response is
queen a4
i mentioned that as a possibility if the
queen left d1 and
now feels like the moment yeah no queen
a4
is really important to to keep an eye on
the queen on d1 was like
perfectly covering everything but at
some point you got to move that queen
to connect the rooks so he's chosen the
king's side b
be on the lookout for robert's queen a4
because that that could be the
difference maker in a lot of positions
like takes on d4
followed by queen a4 there's queen c2
check bishop's hanging on d4
yeah and the e4 pawn as well so
i i really like danny's position he's
trying to figure this out and he looks
like he likes his position the way he's
leaning in right now
he's trying to figure out what's the
right way forward here because there's
so many different options but you should
remember
that the knight can now move from d4
before the bishop on e3 was hanging
now the knight can move because on g1
it's well defended
yep absolutely now the interesting thing
is the knight on e5
and the pawn on h6 work to cover all the
squares on the g
file and the only reason i mentioned
that is after knight e6
i'm thinking how do i attack the g7 pawn
with the queen but there isn't really a
good way to pursue that attack
so even if knight e6 happens and and
danny has to you know trade some
pieces i don't think it's that bad we
could even just get the queen in like
queen a4
as you were mentioning and uh i think
it's still totally totally reasonable
for him
agreed completely so that's maybe the
sort of the idea seems much stronger
than it actually is in practice with the
knight coming e6 so you can avoid it but
what i don't like is danny spending all
this time here
yeah i think he's really conflicted
about trading on d4
or not like i'm not sure he's fully
decided
um i think bishop g1 is one of those
moves where if you didn't play it
then danny would make a quicker move
because he's like oh yeah i got that
knight pinned you know kind of like how
he had it last turn but bishop g1 says
you know look you got to make a serious
decision though that knight's jumping
into e6
if you let me for sure and so
danny's still on the clock this is
actually making me a bit concerned for
him because
even if he plays a good move here in the
next bunch of moves we just saw what
happened in the last game he was down to
18 seconds
lawrence had about a minute and a half
and was able to use time as a weapon
and that could be the case once again
and what do you think of just takes
takes queen a4
to look for a more concrete line um
because at this point i think
danny needs to start thinking about the
fact that two minutes is a lot of time
when there's a lot of pieces on the
board simplifying might just be better
for the
clock situation well i think he spent
all that time wisely because he did in
fact put his queen on a4 here
he's saying i can take on d4 next your
knight cannot move because e4 hangs with
check to boot
so it seems like this position is
turning in danny's favor and queen d1 is
a response that's
not exactly the most inspiring move but
it's a very good practical move
right and wow what what a decision that
was played quickly so he wanted the two
rooks there
if queen takes a4 and
that's probably what he was spending
most of his time on was not
seeing that it's a possibility but
assessing it like would the two rooks be
better than the queen the answers seem
to be yes
it gives a check on that f8 now do you
trade q
i want to keep the queens in the board i
feel like white's king is weaker than
black's king
so i would like to keep the queens in
the war the queen d7 type move
right um queen c4 so same idea
and the question is after like rook c1
i think he wants to play queen d3
that's actually quite annoying because
there's so many tactics there with that
knight landing on d3
yep there's like rook c2 after trading
knight e1 the weirdest fork you've seen
absolutely and then you can consider
taking on d4 like all of these
variations allow
if that knight doesn't move from d4
black can still consider giving up the
bishop for the knight so i really like
this move queen c4
and 12 lawrence is b3 to kick the queen
the queen
jumps back and the a3 pawn becomes the
target as well so
it's not that easy for lawrence to make
a move because there are
very concrete repercussions yep no
matter what
yep i'm trying to find out what what
move we want to play here
like looking at queen c2
strange strange stuff hard move to play
but perhaps
completely reasonable they might be just
trading queens and trading bishops and
knight d3 still at the end because b2
and the f2 square are available
uh for the black rook so he plays b4
well queen a2 is is one move that
comes to mind um yeah
and there's d4 so he takes here
his knight can go into after three queen
eight uh
no queen eight two isn't it knight d or
knight f3 you're gonna win the e4 pawn
by force
yeah that's that's gotta be it and i
would say probably
f3 just because it leads to nastier
stuff after queen e4 and discoveries
yeah and that's that b4 that's a
it's one of those moves where you like
can't contain yourself so you just play
something that is
forcing but then you immediately pay the
price and well this is the price
yep yeah this is and there's not even
going to be time for
counter attack there's no tricky move to
throw in uh for a guy who has 20 seconds
this is just
i think it's clear-cut danny's gonna
take on e4 and he's going to have just
the bounce back game that he needs
yeah and you see danny's face he does
look a lot
more into the match than he did at the
start of this game because he
looked deflated after losing game five
now when you even the score
the momentum sort of shifts
psychologically in your favor
it will be three to three if he's able
to convert this which seems pretty
straightforward at this point there's no
tactic
available to white to confuse danny or
anything
okay well that that'll confuse us but i
don't think it'll confuse danny
no just take on e4 one check on c7 good
for you
king back to g8 that's that the white
king's getting mated very quickly
yeah queenie won and just hope that
he messes the checks out yeah this is
not gonna
so he could have a queen g2 but they
need to calculate do i actually
want to sacrifice anything like getting
checkmated yeah g5 is
classy and the rook and queen coordinate
for mate but i would play knight age
three mate robert after king g1
i like your style of mod knight 3
checkmate was the fancier one and would
have been great
and by the way we have what just over 10
minutes so if
this game goes the distance this will be
our final game
of the longest time control and well we
have a french once again
lawrence going back yeah i don't know
what the stats are
on like games in the five minute portion
because i know that we have
guys like you know magnus and hikaru who
are out here setting records for
the most games but i feel like we've
almost seen the least games
yeah like for for a 75-minute
time patrol only seven games that that's
impressive because that's a serious
average
yeah they're really slowly well it's
because the games have been quite
tight right they've all come down to the
wire both sides down to
about 20 seconds or so so it's been a
close match i do not like this opening
okay
danny needs a pep talk here this is
terrible it is so
unacceptable i think i agree with you
because even knight g4 here looks like a
big problem for white it's almost
winning
right because you're hitting f2 you're
hitting h2 queen h4 i mean this is
we're talking about games going the
distance this game might end very
quickly
yeah i i don't know what danny is
thinking with this opening but i feel
like he
he deflates himself because right after
a good game
he always plays the white pieces and he
plays this
sort of ridiculous french position that
uh he needs to change
honestly in the break yeah this is
in f4 now the bishop just well queen h4
check you lose the bishop on e5 even
maybe that is
acceptable for black but if just bishop
d6 white has created all of these
holes in the position if you castle this
bishop c5 check at the very least
picking up an exchange
so i can't recognize let's let's just
put
castle bishop c5 check king h1 queen h4
h3 um on the board i mean knight f2
queen takes after gg if not bishop takes
h3 leading to more so
right yeah that is uh something he does
not want to do
he's played c3 i i don't think i've seen
it this is -5 according to the
engine robert that's an insane
evaluation that's really
well i mean i guess just bringing the
queen in for a check
if g3 queen h3 the queen slithers into
g2
hits the rook the h2 pawn
if white were already castle queenside i
would still think that black is better
but the fact that you can't develop the
bishop and the queen and get the king
away
no this is just this is this is lost uh
queen g2
um rook f1 knight takes h2 is
is always on the cards um i mean simple
move like
bishop developing and rook over to e8
never hurts either
and as he said danny just he doesn't
have the e3 square so
if he plays like the queen out bishop d2
and castles
there's knight f2 hanging as soon as he
does here waiting for him as soon as he
does that
and he's not even going to get that far
no indeed he will not
and this is something that i'm sure both
players will look at during the break
because
in general in this match it feels like
the player with the black pieces has
been doing better
and uh yeah i think the score reflects
that as well i think four wins for black
if i'm
not mistaken is that right it it
definitely feels that way
um because danny has been doing
well sometimes doing well against that
that english he had that one game where
he just crushed
um he had one one game where it didn't
work out for him but i think he came
back
in that last game and again showed that
um you know he's he's
much better prepared or he's faring a
lot better against the english with the
black pieces
so i agree it's been a tale for for both
players in this match so far yeah so
they are going to use that break to
prepare their openings but i mean look
at this the king on d1
black's not even down a piece by the way
black should be down like a bishop and a
pawn here
and he's not and he's playing c6 of all
moves this just ridiculous
oh gosh i mean white could try bishop d2
king c2 can like
you run away quickly enough maybe you're
not completely hopeless here
well c6 to me is just not uh not enough
conviction in that move i think
knight e3 and maybe getting that bishop
out to g4 with rook e8
um seemed like seemed like that could uh
could definitely work because if white
takes on d5 i mean you just
occupy the d-file and he's regretting it
already
yeah although i wonder in terms of the
greater match strategy
if continuing to play a position like
this can be demoralizing for danny
because
you know he me you know fend it off for
a few moves here i think hey my position
doesn't look quite as bad as it did a
couple moves ago it looks really bad
but then you start giving yourself hope
and then you lose the game anyway and
you're like oh gosh that was
a painful experience that was as bad as
i thought it was yeah
well i think that if he can somehow find
a way to
make this game last the distance and not
give another
game in the five minute portion and
still win it then lawrence is just a god
you know if he can
if he can draw it out and still win it
that's perfect
yeah i'm trying to think here in the
three-minute portion
who's favorite daniel lawrence based on
what you've seen so far today
it's an interesting question i think
probably i want to say lawrence because
danny's time pressure i think is going
to be magnified in
that section um so i feel like uh i feel
like lawrence is is
what i would go with yeah he has been
playing much more slowly but it could
also be because
when you're used to playing three minute
and all of a sudden you play five minute
you
you allow yourself to think more because
like oh this is way more time than i'm
used to
and that obviously doesn't help when
your opponent's playing quickly and well
yeah this position we still have four
minutes and 40 seconds of this time
patrol this is not going to be our last
game unless somehow danny
survives for a few more minutes but it
doesn't look likely no the time i mean
three minute time differential danny is
just uh
is the same poker he's drawing dead yeah
this is
knight takes h2 can you steal a pawn if
you want it
yeah well it comes to f3 as well um
but i think danny would consider that
you know the lesser of two evils at this
point
yeah you get king c2 and rook f1 in you
just feel like you are
on the verge of escaping so that's
better than
you know what it feels like it could be
it still looks bad though
and i see the evaluation bars sinking
lower and lower so black is
clearly very happy here yep
yeah the it's more about just deciding
what your
method of victory is and knight e3 i
think he's going to take back with the
rook
um then followed by like bishop g4 rook
doubling on e8
yeah that looks extremely forcing
and it was king c1
maybe the best move because i did not
see a way out after
taking on e3 and letting the rooks
double yeah that would have been painful
but here i think knight g2 is just
possible to kick the rook away from e1
and
that 92 is falling after it no this is
this is i think he would have to mute
knight g2 with king c2
okay so you're sacrificing the exchange
and saying at least the game continues
yeah at least we're playing at this
point okay he goes rook there but
among other things taking on e2 is
lights out
because there's not even you don't even
have a threat here uh can't play rookie
one and bishop f5 or bishop g4
the maybe the nastier move is coming
next
yeah king b1 actually can be met by like
bishop g4 as you're saying removing the
guard
from this bishop on d2 to win a third
minor piece
for the cost of just one rook too much
material
yep far too much material bishop g4
even knight e3 just trading off more
pieces but i like keeping up the
pressure bishop g4 looks way stronger
as the rook and d1 is under attack
oh man one of these positions where it's
painful for everyone involved it's
painful for danny because he's losing
it's painful for us because we know that
the result is not in question and the
game continues
and for lawrence it's kind of like i
start you start feeling bad for your
opponent right
yeah you're like man this is just so
winning
yeah and this will not be the last game
i mean it seems like danny should be
losing in just a few moves now
especially after b4
bishop f5 comes to mind sink your queen
into d3 on those light squares
but it's possible that it does become
the last game a minute and 50 seconds so
it's getting close
yeah i think we see another one um
just with that 15 seconds rook e8 here
nothing can be challenged knight on g2
is actually so annoying
you loved by rookie one but you can't
because there's a knight there you're
yeah this is this is dunzo
yeah it is rook a2 hey that's a creative
defensive move i like that move
yeah i'll give it to him because rookie
two and king a1 happened at least you're
holding on to that bishop on
d2 for the time being yep
oof queen takes c3 and mate
at least it's over you know yeah and we
will see one more game in this portion
as you can see the game clock ticking
down there's
uh you know little to no chance that
somebody gets mated in less than a
minute in this game
and wow we see brand new signs of life
here
robert with a new opening to end the
portion yeah what do you think
has happened to make lawrence by d4 he
has not been getting good positions for
white so that's probably just the answer
to my own question
but now we have a queen's gambit decline
we went from some g4 g5
mess to the ultra solid queen's gamut
declined
hey what do you think caused him to play
a new open well maybe it was all those
bad positions he was getting with the
white pieces yeah that'll do it
uh i think both people in this match
need to
reevaluate their openings with white
because
to give them credit they're both playing
tremendously with black and we
we need to see more usually the white
pieces are kind of an advantage and
more pronounced than blitz i want to say
but it seems like everything's uh
flipped around for this match so yeah
we're ultra solid
queen scan bit uh declined and and danny
here's
is just gone for you know classic setup
of take that pawn
play b5 and counter attack the center
with c5 very very uh
by the book here yeah that pawn triangle
is no more you know the one from
hit landing on the d5 square but black
gets very quick
activity and wait a second isn't this
uh he's dropping there's some kind of
queen c2 that's bound to happen
yeah he's playing dc five well trade the
bishops after rook
there play dc5 and take h7 and queen c2
yeah i think this was knight takes e4 is
not the move that you should play
for danny yeah this is yeah danny is
realizing that or maybe he's realizing
it right now
now he's realizing it yeah although he
hasn't really moved too much yeah this
is
this is brutal because you play that end
game
and it looks like it will be an end game
you're just down upon this is the worst
way to go into the break he's going to
be suffering
down a pawn in an end game where he's
most likely to lose
and then he's going to be down two games
going into the three-minute portion
where
i would say that lawrence's uh speed
right now is gonna give him the edge
and this end game is so bad that even if
you put a pawn back on h6 white is still
much better
right because the knight is better than
the bishop in an end game
where the bishop has nothing to attack
so yeah this is
not fun not a rook's double the knight
has e5 or d4 to go to
this is i think objectively just winning
for white bishop
wants to go desperately to be seven but
then rook c7 just makes you cry
right so he he does put the rook in d7
first so he can get bishop to b7 but
knight e5 comes to mind
and then rook c7 hit f7 other rook to c1
yeah knight e5 with tempo or if you want
to be very
like prevent counter play style knight
d4
and f4 and then just double double the
rooks on the the c file and go to c7
looks
looks pretty good as well that actually
made me the most practical and
in fact the smartest choice because 95
there is rook d2 and then you just start
thinking about things but
good things yeah i see i see a knight e5
rook d2 and hey there might be
knight f7s there might be rook c7s but i
look at that and i'm like
you know don't need to give him that
much fun i'm with you and he keeps
knight f3 for that purpose no rook d2
for you the bishop on s8 is not hanging
so you
do have one move if you want to play
move like king g7 or something because
if you take on ca twice and this is
what you're showing that there's a rook
d1 checkmate
well danny danny's making it a little
obvious what he's up to over there
yeah no surprises now you put the rook
on d8
and h4 simple king h2 king g3
you can just maneuver your king along
with the dark squares but do not allow
bishop takes f3 so
move that out of the way i'm a big fan
of knight d4
um there's no e5 because the rook is
covering and you just want to get that
rook into
to c7 so 95 and 84 both look very strong
here
95 i will say it looks a little bit
stronger just because the rook's not on
f8 anymore and rook c7
after like a rook d1 trade is going to
come with a lot more poison
it's going to hit the bishop and that
pawn on f7 which is hanging at the
moment
yeah although i really do like the
knight d4 idea you were talking it's
very
instructive just to say i'm going to
close down the position put my net in a
dark square you have a light square
bishop
and you will have zero counter play so i
can then go win the game however i want
so
actually even even if like the better
move is 95
you'll catch me playing knight d4 like
10 times out of 10. yeah
i i'm with you there i think it's just
something you don't even need to think
about you know exactly what's happening
black is stuck struggling to find any
semblance of counter play and here well
there's no counterplay because of the
very direct tactics as man said the
rookstone f8
which means f7 is even more vulnerable
and
i think this is just game over yeah no
it's this is a tough position and
danny's gonna have to live through it uh
as as it is going to be the last
game in the temperature so the time is
officially up and i'm sure it has been
for a couple minutes now but
that'll be it for the five-minute uh
section and these guys will get a break
after this to to reevaluate some
openings but already lawrence must be
looking at d4 and be like wait a minute
why wasn't i playing this the whole
match
yes this this turned out well for him
but it was
a very bad one move mistake by danny and
it's one of those situations where you
release the tension by trading in the
center knight takes up seven by the way
right now is a free pawn
and then the night six comes this is i
would absolutely resign this
like don't want any part of this game
maybe you want a longer break you know
you're gonna lose the game regardless so
you spend the next two minutes in your
clock
and then just have your full break
afterwards if that's what you need
that's smart although i couldn't sit and
stare at this position anymore
yeah for too long yeah um
but yeah this is no this is bad
real bad yeah the the if white can
orchestrate
pawn to f3 pawn e4 then black is really
crying
oh well denny he just you know
grabbed his eyes like i need to see
something new i need to play better
chess
and he did make a one move very bad
mistake in this game so if this opening
is repeated
at least for danny it's easy to see what
went wrong his vision was fine
until he dropped that pawn tactically
whereas in those french positions
i think that that's much more strategic
in nature not just
one simple move change you really need
to have a better foundational
understanding
of that opening and if danny starts
adapting
um and gets good positions with the
white pieces
that flips this match around because it
really feels like lawrence is french at
the moment
is like a free ticket to a good position
and uh that can change
in a heartbeat like danny looks at that
with the engine he starts to collect
himself like
you know okay robert's gonna you know
kill me if i lose to the french anymore
so
i you know i gotta i gotta improve this
and trust me it's not gonna be hard to
find
some lines that lead to an advantage for
sure
and you know just quickly go through the
game explorer see
what the top players are doing against
these certain lines you say wait a
second
white has a pretty good record against
this line hey maybe there's something i
could learn from it but now
lawrence trent out to a two-game lead up
five to three
aman if you were coaching these players
what would you tell them as we head into
the shorter time controls
well uh tell danny that i'm no longer
his coach
and uh if i was being a little more
serious i would i would
sit down look at that french opening
and really be like look this is a
sideline to an opening that's
already has you know shaky reputation
there are lines out there for you
and um you just need to stop allowing e5
there's no way that black is allowed to
play a french like that
get e5 and just get a good position even
the position that you had in game
one robert was was better than this
where he played e5
and maybe he can reevaluate that one um
the positions where the bishop was
getting out to b4
i i like those all better than what
we're seeing so if you're danny
i think you need to collect yourself
realize look you're playing really good
chess with the black pieces
and you're not playing badly with the
white pieces but your openings are just
not giving you
any chance to play well so really
reshape the the whole
structure with the white pieces if
you're in danny's corner i agree with
that and i would say for lawrence
despite the fact he has the lead there
are some things that he can work on as
well every game we play
there are things we can take away from
it and for lawrence i think that he
doesn't need to force the action so much
especially with the white pieces he was
playing these g4 g5 lines
then in this last game he switched he
was the beneficiary of a blunder by
danny dropping a pawn but still i think
that
with a match lead you don't need to take
as much risk you can just settle down
and lawrence is playing quite well
especially when he is given
an opportunity to uh find a tactical uh
option so
with that said ahmad and i are gonna
head to break everybody we will be back
shortly with the three plus one time
patrol of this
i'm not a gm speeches championship match
brought to you by chess.com
just because this match will end today
does not mean that there's not more
chance to be enjoyed tomorrow as
arena kings season six begins monday
january 11th that is tomorrow
5 p.m pacific time so you know you can
do the conversion to wherever you live
but it will be a ton of fun
a lot of streamers will be taking part
uh amman the chess bras myself
you know you who's who of the chest
stream world will be enjoying
the arena kings but for now oman we are
stuck in the i'm not a gm speed chess
championship sphere
and lawrence trent up two games in this
match
i was thinking during our short break
there that danny you know he gets the
white piece in the next game
i think that he's going to go for it i
think he's going to play something
super aggressive he'll have looked at
the french lines but i'm not sure he
needs to
worry himself just yet there's plenty of
time left what do you think should he
play for win maybe at all costs right
now or play something a little bit more
relaxed
and just let the best chess come down
yeah i think uh danny definitely does
not need to overreact these matches
are long for a reason and you can
collect a lot of points in the bullet
portion
and we've seen deficits like crazy
deficits made up in just the bullet
portion where
i think you and i maybe give that slight
nod to to danny as the
uh more comfortable player in that
format but uh lawrence is kind of more
of a question mark
in in that regard that we we don't know
what to expect from him there
but if you're danny no need to panic um
i think or i hope
that he's changed things up a little bit
in the break i'm assuming he's done so
i think that the three-minute portion is
maybe gonna just be a bit more familiar
uh to him robert as you know most
players when they play online they're
used to three-minute chess
yeah and i think that's the biggest
thing is you see a deficit scoreboard
you
start getting in your own head i'm
losing i need to catch up but
danny i would say is the stronger two in
bullet time patrols
he definitely has more experience and i
just looked he is the slightly higher
rated of the two
in bullets so you know if you can think
i just need to be within one
two games to give myself a chance and
bullet don't
just rush here don't say i need to win
now and then end up losing the games you
cannot play for results
you need to be as objective as you
possibly can be and with the white
pieces
starting here in just a second in the
three minute time patrol
i think that danny does not need to just
play hyper aggressive chess
he can play his normal stuff yeah and
speaking of not
needing to play hyper aggressive that
was the advice that you had for lawrence
ironically so
it seems like the advice overall is
everyone just calm down a little bit
you know uh both guys have shown that
they they can play some really good
chess
and we've seen you know a very crushing
game
just on the board from both sides so we
know that it's there
and sometimes when you have a crushing
game like that
you really start feeling yourself the
next game you just go for something
way too aggressive so don't need to do
that keep it under control
now we're back to this french is danny
gonna have something prepared here
because he can't keep walking into these
lines and there
we have it bishop b5 which is a way to
pin the knight on c6
it also allows you to take over the e5
square black if you take on e5
the knight will end up replacing the
pawn once you capture on
c6 first this is what's happening so
lauren's accepting
the slightly more passive position for
the time being but says i have the two
bishops maybe down the line
i can gain some open space and use them
to my advantage
yeah already it doesn't matter what
happens in this game
i like the opening better no matter what
so this is already successful
for danny he's got a position here and
i actually don't mind it for lawrence at
all but the bottom line is that
this this is already better for for
danny then than what we saw at least
we have a game here yeah it feels like
they're playing on relatively equal
footing
rather than lawrence just having the
advantage of move eight and
if you look at this position it's closed
down and in a closed position
knights tend to be quite good against
bishops look at this bishop on c6
where's that piece going it's staring
into its own pawn on d5 so black's best
move
it might be d5 off the board my bishop
one c6 is great right
that's what you want just you take that
pawn straight out of the game and we see
f5 g6 like he's trying to make that
bishop as sad as possible
robert he's putting all his pawns on
light squares and he's going for g5
and that's thematic he's a way to open
up the king side because only white's
king
is on that flank whereas white would
like to play a4
b4 b5 so we actually may see a very
aggressive game
from both players here but i have a
little bit more belief
in white's attack than i do in blacks
considering black doesn't have those
pieces developed on the king side
yeah and although you know both sides
are going to be attacking
h6 feels very natural but i would have
given a real consideration to knight h6
first
getting it to f7 then h6 bishop e7 and
it kind of feels like you're almost
playing a benoni um on the opposite side
of the board here on the king side where
you're really trying to get that g5
break in but
your knight on g8 just can't help that
break
at all right and well
this is an interesting little move order
situation where
danny start with b4 rather than a4 and
lawrence
plugged the a4 scope with his bishop so
i actually think dana might regret that
decision
to start with b4 even if his position is
fine now i'm looking
at the evaluation bar on screen says
about level i think that playing a4
first
made his play much easier to follow up
yep start with a4 and then you can even
take
you take it slow with b3 or you can
continue b4 b5 now
queen h5 which looks like you know makes
the biggest threat in the game is nicely
met by knight g3 hitting the queen and
covering each one
totally and another concern i'm having
long term is that if this bishop comes
to b5 at the right moment you don't
escape with king f1 king e2 so king f1
here
is not a bishop b5 check and that's a
problem nice
nice yeah that's good to keep in mind
that that diagonal will
always belong to black yes
and i like the way danny's playing by
the way with g3 king g2
rook h1 trade off the aggressive pieces
because without the rooks on the board
you have
no attack
so now is the time for just king
g2 rook h1 here i i like that
but then i saw the uh evaluation bar
kind of go up a lot so i'm
looking where's the tactic yeah it
looked like maybe just you're gonna
take time for a bishop f6 um and then
king g2 might have just been
um a bit better i'm not sure get the
rook off the h5
no i think you're completely right
that's what it was because kicking the
rooks off the h-file is
a great idea now for example black has
rook h2 check
sacrificing material that's why rook h1
takes care of all those tactics and
white is up a pawn the e6 pawn remains a
weakness
and without the rooks where's your
attack coming from
oops uh rook h4 uh was coming to mind
there
as an idea not sure about that but
bishop h4 he's just looking to plug the
uh
plug the entire thing and say look
you're not operating on the h file but
i'm not sure i'm a fan of this now no
maybe depending on
from the bishops and the fact that all
the play is
on the kings side and i see the
the bar it just dipped a lot bishop
takes g5 of a rook h2 check
this is a big problem the knight on f3
overloaded defending the bishop one g5
and covering the h2 square that's that
was a bad move bishop h4 then right back
to g5
clearly danny lost the threat so it's
gonna be
takes h2 uh takes h2 king
f3 and then like queen queen g8 or queen
queen somewhere hit the knight yeah that
looks scary to bring your
king out to f3 but i think your ultimate
point is maybe you're gonna have to
sacrifice your queen on
f2 for a rook that lands there and so
that's
maybe you bring your knight back to h3
at the end knight h3 here
and then queen how does that queen
attack the knights queen h8 is
a potential move to just put all your
forces against that
knight h3 exactly yeah
now this is in daddy's clock his his
posture
his hand on his head right now all seem
to indicate that
he is unfortunate for him blundered
quite a bit
oh this is this is really rough i would
even
consider like bishop b5 to like stop the
king from going to e2
oh danny let's go king f4
i like that move actually because i
don't see an immediate
checkmate and yeah okay queen
came to h5 that's a strong move yeah it
really is
okay good response rook takes h3 pick up
the two knights for your rook the queen
h6 would be
maybe an underrated move here but rick
h3 is is solid
queen h6 is so beautiful just painting
the net in g5 so you can
steal the knight in h3 for free oh he
goes for it
that's a tough move to face and in the
king f3 probably the best move
now h3 is always hanging you can get
that bishop involved maybe if you want
to
bishop b5 looks pretty good he ends up
taking all right that makes sense
okay at least danny's got some moves
like he's he's figured out hey i can
shuffle my king depending on where the
queen is that's
good to know right and where's the
checkmate
how does this game conclude right
how about two queen h2 queen e1 only
move
what about bishop f1
that's just disgusting it threatens
queen age once
like h1 me the king can go up to f4 but
bishop f1 you can't take it because in
that h2
i think it's just a good move i think
it's the probably the best move
knight h2 mate is the threat
that's dirty that's dirty well
wait white's kind of why it's kind of
yeah
like queen h4 okay yeah yeah
king wait now the king's kind of safe
i mean oh danny's getting a in yeah
black is still obviously better
but where do you how do you win this
game no this is
not that easy i think you got to bring
the king king c6 let's go
oh actually that's great king c6 it's
time for king c6 they're both
uh basically they're both moving a bunch
of
quick moves they're trying to gain time
on the clock right so queen
whoa what's with queen tiggs yeah that
that looks
queen d3 queen d2 coming oh good movie
i like danny's energy here whoa okay oh
yeah that's not gonna help yourself that
was not the energy
you were right though he was doing
everything that he needed oh f3 is
hanging at the end of this
okay he doesn't take it not for danny
yeah okay
yeah this is not going to work out no
this is what you call just
bullet madness and a win for lawrence
trent
yeah g4 oh g4 was at least playable
there
just uh hope that a mistake is made
but no the pawns are too strong knight
d3 check e2 e1
game over
danny had his chances there that was
actually an insane comeback
um it's kind of surprising but not
seeing your bishop f1
like insane kind of winning move and it
actually meant that
maybe it wasn't so winning after all
like you missed that one thing
it didn't look that easy no it certainly
didn't and
here we see that we have already in very
offbeat obscure position where the
knight is on d6
and it's even material but the pawns
have been captured the b
pawn for the e pawn i think this is the
kind of
position danny is striving for because
of the match situation
and i think that for lauren oh gosh oh
boy
is it gonna be a mate in the diagonal
not sure danny's striving for this
this is looking sketchy that night on b8
is not a participant and
there were a few moves in a row where
danny had like
he takes d5 available uh quote-unquote
winning
that pawn and he didn't go for it and i
mean i'm sure it's based on a little bit
on some theory there but
i'm not sure if that was smart because
now you take it knight takes d5
on top of just the queen d3 which bishop
b1 really gets ready for
yeah you can't play f5 because e6 is
hanging i mean just
okay by g6 because the pawn h6 is
hanging this feels
not like tilt exactly i think that danny
played
this opening to try to have some winning
chances as early as move
two or whatever but yeah this is not
going well
that's for sure no it can't be um so
what's the answer after queen d3
um is he is he kind of like playing
no not knight f5
b6 what's he up to yeah what what's that
that's
seems kind of irrelevant but maybe it's
somehow right
well basically he doesn't want to open
the position up and he's
saying like i think queen c2 queen d3
stuff
is good enough on the king side what's
going on on the queen side well i just
want to shut that down
the knight on b8 importantly cannot join
the game and it could maybe via a6 had
he reacted differently
it's a really good point so saying the
quantity is less important than how
the quality of the pieces are at play
here but now i mean can't black play
some kind of bishop e4 seems oh
that's a that's a sacrifice for me
you're hitting the rook on a8
and mate on h7 that's just winning yeah
f takes e4 rook takes e4 as a mons point
and that looks
that just looks great yup that looks
great queen d5
uh maybe is like a move but yeah i'm
taking on e4 there
nice and easy bishop takes h6 is about
to crack the entire game open
oh gosh you know just pick that rook up
move it to some square like rook b4
would be a winning move to go queen to
checkmate the pawn e6 helping out
yeah this is this is game over this is a
big problem danny's down a minute and i
want to stress
that the time difference is more
meaningful in a three minute game so if
you're down a minute five minute chest
you know
that's not the same as being down a
minute in three minute chests and
uh it's probably the worst to be down a
minute in one minute chess
agreed yeah i think it does get worse
than that
and by the way i've seen international
master teddy coleman the chat who
played against danny last year and he
said i was up four games
against danny heading into bullet he
actually caught up so danny's bullet
chest does give him chances but not the
way he's currently playing he is playing
to win from move one not with his moves
but with his wishes and that's a big
problem
what do you think of queen h7 and bishop
g6 followed by something slow like
bishop d2
i love it it looks just king f6 bishop
d2
you play rook e1 and then bishop c3 and
uh
bishop h5 there's so many so many
crushes there i would go
queen h7 but he's faced with a free rook
in the corner so
it's the luxury of choice that might uh
might come back to bite him here
and you have to give credit to lawrence
for spending his time here a lot of us
would say oh it's a free rook oh there's
a check on h7 and make one of those
moves
but he's trying to figure out which one
is better he does go for mons
check and check queen can't take on g6
and that e5 check picks up the queen
and here comes your bishop oh should be
four
g6 is mate oh that's nice can't fault
bishop e4
i mean he wants to pick up the rook in a
better way and leave the guy's king
on f6 i think it's it's all winning here
yeah that's that's pretty nice lauren's
figured everything out
and queen f7 queen f5 it's also me
oh gosh yeah this is really
painful and if you're danny you probably
want to resign and just get the next
game going
okay get the next one started getting
into that territory where you need as
many games as possible
and so you're down what right now
white is down in exchange but the rook
on eight can be picked up
for free and so white's gonna be up a
full piece with an attack
so it's important i don't have three
covers e1 just to point it out for
everybody there's no background
checkmate
but with white with such a big advantage
here
i think resigning and starting the next
game as soon as possible is the right
move
totally yep and there's
there's not many moves left that are
good or playable for uh for danny brooke
e1 is going to be lights out
the d5 pawn is loose so the queen has to
always watch it
each bishop takes h6 is also in the
position some sort of combination of
those two moves looks
looks decent yeah bishop takes h6
queen e6 bishop takes d5 check it just
at the very least you win two pawns
because you're already up a piece so you
give a piece back for two pawns
and then there's probably checkmate on
top of that
yep grab a full piece bishop b7 is also
playable
let's not forget like that's a move you
know i wouldn't even think about it but
it's probably the best move
yeah i wouldn't be surprised oh gosh
yeah that looks
really good queen f5 check should be
mentioned as well he takes on h6
yeah i think he's going for that line
and it says matin too knight g5 and
queen g7
is yeah that's lights out there it is
that's checkmate and that's a four game
lead
for lawrence trent yeah and keep in mind
this it this was 3-2 for danny
at some point wasn't it and now it's i
feel like it's been four games in a row
yeah we were five in a row is that no it
was three two lawrence it was two to one
danny and then two to one
okay that's right it has been four games
in early you're actually
you're completely correct about that so
we have this setup again i like this for
white
from the point of view that you have the
knights the position is closed
and lawrence is the one thinking right
now and still plenty of time for each
player
but he's trying to figure out how do i
properly play this position
so that yeah it's not just closed down
oh the g6 square is
i'm eyeing that one but so danny has
played a4 before b4 he's definitely
learned that
and that's an immediate adaptation and
meanwhile lawrence is saying look i
didn't like the way that g5 i had to
sack a pawn to get the
you know h file open last time so he's
going for h6 g5 first
gives up a big square on e5 there and i
think danny
should be happy with what what he's got
yeah ecstatic i mean
what more could you ask for b5 is a huge
threat because you can't ever
open the a file oh my goodness i mean b5
is the move i would play if it's a
bullet without even thinking but
maybe you do lose the pawn and you could
regret it so
not my pieces happy to play b5 and his
game
he probably should think about it before
doing it yeah i would maybe insert like
a rookie one
um first just to get on that e file it
feels like that's where
you're going to want to be no matter
what um whereas the e4 square you're
always taking care
playing f3 so kind of makes me stay away
from moves like f4
being a little bit too aggressive there
on the king side i think it's uh you
know
ideas like b5 uh takes takes bishop a3
um kind of what he wants to go for and
yeah he started with rookie one just a
slow approach
yeah and i'm reading chat and i see a
comment there
lawrence he's doing the dumbbell thing
again
yeah he's got the
he's getting a quick workout in did he
watch the
the last match between alexandra and
greg shahadi where alexandra started the
match with some workout weights
and do you see the movement but h5
giving him the g5 on for free
yeah i think that he should do more of
the flexing over the board and less so
uh with the weights because he just
dropped the big pawn for free yeah it
seems like maybe the blood
left his head went over the biceps for a
moment there
h5 is on the board and i'm not sure
danny's gonna be too concerned seeing
that i think
this is a one of the one of the games
where danny just i think has a
massive edge and needs to win this game
for the match situation
for sure he's winning he won a pawn now
he's winning in exchange because once
the knight moves
the rook on d8 will be captured and
there's still some chances for lawrence
because of the opening of the king side
not too many white pieces on that flank
but objectively the position is
overwhelmingly strong
for danny just take that rook on d8 next
yeah and knight e4
is even worse because it will result in
um well after we exchange everything
a trade of queens which you can't allow
so
yeah what he's done here makes a bit
more sense knight g4
more aggressive move but i mean takes d8
h3 to kick the knight out it's always
there
h5 pawn hanging h3 what a good move and
danny plays it saying
that night even if it's not doing
anything just yet there could be
some potential for it especially if the
queen landed on d8 so the queen go to h4
next
let me first kick that knight out and
then figure out if i
actually want to take the exchange and
now take on d8 just
give me that rook and doesn't that win
even more things than before and now
he's gonna
have a full rook i don't know if that's
enough material but it does look very
strong i think
lawrence was trying to rely on some kind
of knight takes f2 and opening the
g-file and
things like that but it feels i thought
maybe h4 by lawrence was like the
trickier
kind of in-between move to play and he
has gone for this but
he wants d4 and hitting the g2 pawn but
this is something you can just
sit back and tell yourself okay this
doesn't work
you can just start with that tell
yourself that and then find out why
bishop takes h4 seems like a good
starting point you're up a rook
and a piece at this point and queen g4
also has to be a good move because if
you can trade the queens off
even if you lose both the knight first
and g3 than the bishop one date you
still have a rook for a bishop and
several extra pawns
important to note rook f8 is bishop f6
otherwise
that would be a big catastrophe so
yeah danny worked through this and
figured out his bishop f6 very important
move queen f3 here
keep offering the queen exchange don't
let
lawrence keep those on the board even if
he does keeping the board white is doing
well but
i would try to play queen f3 here and
definitely
everything's coming off everything's
coming off queen c2 check there's rook
e2 yep and he's gonna have to trade that
and yeah he got an outside pass pawn
here i think it's pretty reliable he's
gonna put that rook
on d4 and the other rook maybe to each
one and just push push push
push him baby where's the officer when
you need him just h4
h5 and there it goes yep and
you know lauren says he's picking up
that pawn he's going to try to cement
that bishop on f5
it's not going to be good enough but it
is it is a good try i mean
florence was basically down a rook at
some point and hey he's got this
position
in a three-minute game it's pretty
reasonable but i think if danny plays
this one right
uh correctly he'll be he'll be fine yeah
and it's one of these positions where
you can give up your pawn e5 if you play
f4 you give up some of these important
light squares that could
be tricky but as long as you can kick
this rook off of h5 and play h5 yourself
so rook g4 here
i don't care for my e5 pawn i just want
to sprint that pawn with the board danny
does so and
yeah love that move um if the rook takes
an e5 as you mentioned
h5 h6 and the rook on e5 blocked by its
own e pun it's just really hard to get
back in defense
exactly and so lauren's also down on
time
rook g5 now just bring your rook out
step by step by step
although you can't get the g6 don't
blend to that
yeah i think what if you ever have a
chance you want to sack your rook for
that bishop as well like bishop f5 you
snap that off the board and bring your
king
in yeah he's just no king of 14 g5 the
good old-fashioned oh with the other
direction
nope not sure why
oh look there's rook f7 rook f6 that's
annoying yeah
that's annoying so
a382 and rook takes a h5 like the h pawn
in general
and danny gives up that pawn disagree
big disagree
yeah this is still very good for white
but much harder to convert
absolutely so rook a7 there's king b6
king b6 and bishop kind of goes to f5
this is not the conversion that you need
here
can you no don't take yet but you can at
some point consider taking that
bishop one f5 yeah king d2 and rook b4
rook f4 good move oh no
that should be three check oh my
goodness oh
and danny is very frustrated here as he
should be
yeah danny danny might lose this game
very very possible yeah that was a good
move though
because c5 pushing those pawns yes take
that and f4
danny you you're really at risk of
losing here wait
you could win now again because well
he's supposed to win he's up on time and
it's uh
takes d4 takes uh oh
rook f4 takes and you queen with check
but white white has the extra pawn
okay so that was sneaky from lawrence
though yeah and if queen c2 is queen e4
check so that's why i went king here
extreme queen c5 okay repeat now king g4
okay no checks nicely done no checks is
the worst feeling
okay now goes the pawn but there might
be oh quindy finds queen e5 check so you
couldn't
check uh from over there queen h3 is the
nasty check though
yeah gotta go f6 queen h4 i mean h6
queen h6 was the draw or this is good
too
yeah wow yeah i think danny had to get
his queen
back close to that pawn um just spend a
move
bring it back and often those queen end
games are the ones that you usually win
um are we do we have a break or
we do the players get a mid time control
break so they can
refresh themselves danny will have the
black pieces when we resume but for now
lawrence trent enjoys himself a four
game lead and amman
that game just there that has to just
crush your spirits if you're danny
because
you had to win in the bag a million
times over yeah
you you have the the h-pawn pushing
you're up a rook at one point
up a piece in exchange you name it uh
danny had it in that game and
that was the first time that we've seen
him prosecute a good
opening into an advantage into what
should have been a win
and if lawrence is getting away with
even those plus he's winning some games
himself
i don't think danny has a road to a
comeback unless he can turn some of
these games around and at least get back
on the board for his confidence
and we will see when we return just a
few minutes for more action from the
i'm now gm speechless championship
brought to you by chess.com
and we are back ready for the second
half of this three plus one
second increment time patrol among we
know that lawrence is out to a big lead
danny has played some impressive chess
along the way
but the results not matching his level
of play i'd say
yeah no uh i i think this match has been
a little more psychological like lauren
says felt like he's had the upper hand
in most time scrambles felt like he's
just been up
on time in general on the clock and as i
mentioned i think that becomes more
pronounced and
we've seen that in the three-minute
section lawrence
trent has really run away with the match
a little bit
in this format so in the second half of
this this format here
after the break danny is really going to
have to uh come back
just collect himself and get a few
points on the board because
i think if this trend keeps up with the
points lawrence's scoring
even if danny makes a comeback in the
bullet it's gonna be very hard to make
up this kind of distance
i agree and you know in game seven when
danny lost that one then he had one
final game the five-minute time patrol
he lost that as well we blew under the
pawn
uh on h7 with check and the c5 square so
it seems that things have just been
getting out of control for him and now
with the black pieces he needs to stop
that spiral and right now he brings his
knight to e4 this is a common idea
that if you can play f5 you feel pretty
decent about your position however
i think knight fd2 instead of rook to e1
was a good move there
yeah but i was going to point out
something interesting that happened that
was just a product of the players not
being stopped
was that uh lawrence played this opening
and
got to see that danny was going to play
the queen's indian
and then the game was aborted and then
they took a break so
it's just kind of weird danny hadn't
played that before lauren's probably
went in the break like
yeah i might take a look at a few lines
in the queen's indian all of a sudden
yeah you know it does give him a little
bit of insight into his opponent's
repertoire here but i like black's
position i tend to
in these openings because you look at
these double c pawns and they're
stuck in place you don't even need to
play c5 which sometimes is a good move
to then try to open the c file look at
this
queen c8 it gives you more flexibility
the queen could come directly to a6 or
you could play c5 and just that c4
square it feels
very vulnerable here yeah i mean queen
a6
and sometimes even trading the c7 pawn
for the c4 pawn
could be in black's favor just to get
that end game bring the rook to the to
the c
file and not deal with any tactics and
maybe that's the type of game that
danny wants and he really can't excel in
i'm with you there because
you know in theory you're like i don't
give a pawn c7 for double pawn and c4
but there's that backwards pawn on c3
that always has to
have an eye kept out on it so he said he
plays bishop f6
which makes it move like knight e5 a
little bit less
welcome and maybe c5 comes in where
there are more tactics available and
h4 by lawrence just playing on the king
side here
what's the point yeah well i think after
queen a6
he's generally looking to immediate with
knight d2 um to keep that under control
and in the meantime after knight d2 or
regardless of that move i think he was
looking at the move
uh maybe d5 and maybe e4 just to kind of
break things open say look you've got a
knight and a queen
that are really offside on the queen
side i'm looking to play
on the king side with e4 d5 maybe h5 at
some point
h6 and say that look your pieces are on
the wrong side of the board
to help defend yeah that actually makes
perfect sense so
that's why danny i guess brought queen
in from c8 to c6
wait what isn't c4 pawn just i mean rook
b4
was really called calling to be played
it
danny did something a little tricky by
the way he played queen b7 and then
queen c6 and
lawrence was probably like knight d
tubes
just it wasn't working for him because
it was pinned so that that was sneaky by
danny but i think lawrence did have rook
before
to to cover things or there was maybe
bishop e7 what a weird
position he probably had that but it
looks very awkward and that's why
lawrence quickly went king h2 and rook
g1 and objectively black's position is
great here
but we've seen in the past lawrence
getting himself in a tactical position
where he has come out on top and
if he can make g4 work and open up the g
file bring the second rook over there
you could see the black king getting in
some danger but for now
with that knight coming into e4 for
example it feels like black should be
very happy here
yep g4
and this was expected whether it's good
or not
it was expected um i think you could
give
uh consideration to queen e4 if you're
you're trying to try to get the queens
off the board knowing that the end games
are going to be good for you
yeah e4 looks like a great move too
hello queenie for it it's
the practical choice just like let's
trade these pieces off although here
queen takes c3 i guess you can
accomplish that while stealing another
pawn oh but d7s hanging
more things to calculate yeah things
just a bunch of things
uh i guess queen e6
is it's also possible trying to play d6
saying look f2 is hanging but
at the same time white wants to play f3
kick that night out
and and then continue from there yeah
and h4
is hanging but are you in time to
capture that your move f3 looks very
strong here
just to kick the knight out but knight
d6 can be played as a simple response
and what's the follow how does white
take advantage of the fact that you
kicked piece in the last couple moves
and
can you take on h4 i want to take that
pawn
but i'm somewhat worried that i'm
opening the position up even more
and i know i'm up a second pawn but
opening files
yeah you have to deal with the move c5
as well after bishop takes h4 just as
like kind of a hit
on on your piece there and then maybe d5
follows up hits your queen
i think lawrence is doing the right
thing which is hey
your position is already a little
questionable why don't you dare your
opponent to take another pawn which
usually people don't want to do they're
like ah that feels a little too greedy
so
um he's sort of maybe leaving it there a
little bit like a bluff but
i like what danny's doing he's more
controlled don't worry about that pawn
trade pieces yeah it's great choice
knight takes f7 rook f7 bishop takes c7
looks like a hanging pawn
but then you play d6 and the bishop gets
trapped on c7 so
there are tactics still available in
this position
c6 yeah c6 looks strong just kicking the
rook right
away from defense of the night now yeah
that's just material
i think he wanted some knight f7
trickery
you know and brook takes f5 but after
knight f7 you can take that rook on b5
you can and you will that's just
scooping up material
and looks great for danny so he's
playing a really nice game
after what must have been just this like
hurtful game where he didn't win right
before the break now
he took on f7
curse i'm sorry i i i'm so sorry
that's how does that happen take the
rook there's no threats for a night on
f7
um so you don't trust yourself that's
that's what happens
oh this is heartbreaking yeah because
you can't take
yeah i was gonna say you can't take on
d6 even the bishops just lost g5 may as
well chuck that in there
yeah just nope g5
okay wow on to the next game
for danny it's like even when he plays
these great games
at the start he's not playing them start
to finish he's playing them start to
like
two moves before the finish every time
and that's not enough
it really feels like he doesn't trust
himself and the game before the break
was different because he was just
winning heading towards the end game
that game there were still
complications to be figured out and he
didn't take the rook on b5 because he
probably oh the knight will give me a
check or there's something against my
king
whereas if you gave danny even you know
uh freshly
that position on new day he'll just
crude and
what is this a5 i mean this has to be
horrible for black even b4 here
looks very reasonable and danny danny is
probably at the point where he's like
listen at this point i don't care if i
trust myself it's time for b4 i'm down
in the match we have to turn this around
somehow and
i think maybe that was the kick he
needed he's like this is not acceptable
just b4 let's go and i like his position
right here this looks
horrible for black because yeah you're
up a pawn but you're down
several moves in terms of development
it's so easy for white's play rook
rook to be one yeah which
files we want to operate we can play
rook c1 we play rook b1
and then our knight to e1 knight to d3
for example
oh yeah he's just pushing a5
there's there's uh okay knight h6 he
wants knight f7 g5
um but i i just think that's too slow
you just don't care right you grab all
your pieces and you just throw them on
the queen side wherever they'll go
but how do you actually end this game
like that's the annoying thing is of
course white's attack looks strong
and he just puts his not enough force
there's no attack for you i've hurt your
pawn structure
you can go knight d3 or knight both are
good
to take those dark squares even so
is it time for something as slow as like
knight d2
move the queen knight b3 knight c5 like
knight on c5 feels
like you're closing in on the end of the
game but you do
you do move everything away from the the
king at that point
yeah i think he's thinking about it
though i think that's his point
right 92 he does it yeah it's definitely
his plan i don't think it's the right
one but it is what he's going for
yeah if you double the rooks and the g
file at the end of it white plays g3 and
says
okay what'd you accomplish here yeah
that's a
good move i imagine because of 1983
you can play like bishop c4
do you want to even just take take the
knight and say look if you play a6 i got
b6 and knight c5 i'll take it
at all times i'm somewhat concerned that
you know once you give up the bishop
then the knight moves away and the b7
pawn becomes a very big target but
maybe you are right that you have to do
this and just hope that it works out
just
it feels not great whoa okay knight c5
and i would use the knight that's not
attacked or sorry the knight date is
attacked it's an idea
i see e3 to c5 yeah looks reasonable
and yeah trading queens doesn't feel
good when you're down a pawn but even
there
white has a good position because e6
pawn is the weakest pawn but he does
play
his knight is it gonna is it gonna be
bishop uh
c4 here
knight takes beasts i don't know if it
works but i'm
trying to make the attack work yeah
knight b7
it's a rook g6 yeah that's i mean
good question hey what's next for white
over there
i don't know g6 is nice because it
guards e6 nice little multi-purpose move
there
yeah you can double the rooks you
protect the pawns your queen is free a6
played b6 uh b6 immediately
so where does your queen is bc5 a threat
because knight a5 could be a response so
like
perhaps you can give up this knight on
c5 but
right the bc knight a5
is is interested there is queen b6 after
that so i'm not fully convinced but
um it's definitely something to keep in
mind otherwise if you're just trading
queens here then a6 is horrible
and you can't even trade queens right
because knight a4 takes a4 and knight e4
just take that so
yeah what's the play here an extra
minute
for lawrence as well
maybe like rook c1 and then if you take
on
a c5 then you go knight a5 and you have
uh like
dc at the end maybe we just start with
knight a5
he played rook c1 so he's going for this
kind of line here but
yeah this is very sketchy i think he's
going knight a5
i don't trust it no i don't trust that
even queen e8 can i just run away
that knight v7 at least it's tricky
right it's tricky
queen a5 it's c4 c4 and
that's it yeah no more attack for you
no c4 hurts here and look at the time
he's just gonna resign he's just like
had enough of that had enough with the
way that he's playing and i think
i think danny's at the point where it's
not that he doesn't trust himself
anymore he's just like
he he's he's not having anything go his
way
even when it looks like the position is
so dominating i feel like he kind of
stopped calculating
that game at some point and he was just
like yeah let's you know intuition let's
just throw these pieces
and then all of a sudden you can't throw
them anymore
ran out of them yeah the thing that
lawrence is doing best of all is playing
very quickly so even when he gets into
some
shaky territory he's able to use the
clock
to his advantage and danny hasn't been
able to figure this out throughout the
day and here
is another example that's just pawnee
four and after ponzi for maybe just
even take it again with your knight or
play e3 it's
not a position that looks particularly
good for black e3 or bishop e3
he's got bishop f4 and he's opened up a
six point
lead now and i think g5
i mean i don't know how much he's
calculated g5 but it looked like he was
almost ready to play bishop c7 knight d5
take
f6 and fe yeah looked worthwhile for
sure
and that's why neither player you know
gets to
see that happen knight e7 play that's a
good move knight g6 to go and get that
bishop
on f4 and that would make e3 and other
squares
more vulnerable so i actually think that
danny's position is good here
and he's moving quickly so that's the
big end in the position he is moving
very quickly so he should be able to
continue
improving his position i don't mind c6
it kind of looks bad at first sight but
bishop c8 bishop f5 or even just the e6
queen d7
the knight on c3 is the piece that needs
improving if that knight was on
f3 there'd be an e5 square waiting but
knight on c3 is not a great piece here
and e4 is looking to try to remedy that
yeah and he's giving up a pawn because
the pawn takes e4 the d4 pawn is under
attack
with check but what lawrence wants to do
is get that knight to d6 and just
starting to create some
very concrete issues for danny's minor
pieces so he does
take with the queen on d4 i think that
lawrence will
not trade yeah maybe king h1
yeah i like that because you can then
win the bishop pair
and that could be a problem whereas if
you take on d4 oh okay so it goes bishop
e3 instead
he wants the bishop on d6
or sorry on f6 followed by like a queen
d7 and really really getting in there
yeah though the fact that his rook's no
longer c1 is a problem because with the
rook on c1 you'd have 96 ideas
but now isn't black just up a pawn
yeah that wasn't the best by lawrence
but i don't think you're
too concerned here if you're playing
white because that blockade
is fantastic on d4 yeah and if rooks
come off the board it's immediately
going to be a
drawn position so yeah i think white can
just play king f2 next and troubling
rookie one
and not that he did this intentionally
but match strategy there's seven and a
half
minutes ticking down here uh i'm not
sure this is
the best for danny because he's gonna
play this a while and he
has a good chance to not win it yeah so
i i can't really force a draw right
there's no way for danny just
oh you must make this draw otherwise you
lose no i mean lawrence can just kind of
maneuver around for a while yep yeah
that's not good
although if you play this long enough
and lauren starts getting time travel
that's how danny could win this game
yeah no there's definitely a chance
danny wins it but it's almost like
danny's gonna win this game it's gonna
take so long that
you start even wondering if it's worth
it but but
yeah i think i think danny should play
this on hey he's up upon
this is his this is a chance absolutely
although i like what lawrence just did
because he's gonna play rook d4
and he does so if the rooks are traded
no winning chances
for immediate draw and oh danny is
admitting it's a it's a draw but
lawrence doesn't have to take the draw
right away no lauren should be smart but
king e3 then played bishop h8 bishop g7
bishop c3 just
used that bishop on a yo-yo string on
the diagonal and
waste time and that's exactly what he's
doing
and if i'm danny i'm not making moves
like a5 i don't want a new position i
want the same position
i want to make that draw
yeah this is not this is not what you
want danny offered to draw
and he took it wow look at that
would you have taken that draw given the
fact that you're up six points here
i feel like it's the considerate thing
to do from a
broader games you know gameship point of
view but
i think that you know why would you
because you can waste time like for your
own benefit i don't know it's one of
these situations i always find tricky
because
i i would think that i wouldn't want to
do that but if it helps me win the match
which is what my goal is then
i don't know it's you've done nothing
wrong by playing on
okay this is speaking of doing things
wrong this opening has to stop
from lawrence yeah the problem is he's
winning the games
so what you know like it he's gonna have
to take a beating
for it to just okay now now it's gotta
stop
this this this one danny you got it
buddy i mean
put him away this is this is too much
here
too much just b5 queen b3 pawn c4
just throw all your pieces forward it
doesn't rush it and this is
not good at all for black nope
f3 looks maybe unnecessary but i
understand it
like didn't want to see pawn f3 on the
board but
looked unnecessary and gives away some
squares for no reason
agreed so queen
queen b3 looks very logical here
yes yeah queen v3 or a b5
in some order what is black aiming for
in this position i think i think he's
just playing like knight f5
bishop e7 h5 g4 like he's just kind of
doing that i don't think that he
believes in his position but
hey it's solid and there's if there's no
breakthrough
on the queen side he's just he's just
hanging out yeah you're right it
actually has a field where h5 g4 rook g4
even though the f4 pawn drops at least
you can look at that reaction
h3 it's just not like you don't need you
don't need that move
yeah it typically helps black because
then you're opening up more lines when
you get g4
yeah like if g4 happens in that pawns on
h2 the most that can happen is the
g file opens up and now after g4
the g file could open up by taking on h3
and if you take first that's two files
open up no matter what
yeah so how does danny actually increase
his attack here because
rook c14 with c4 as an idea he plays a6
trying to just open up the b file but
can you
take and run your king to d7 and just
run away i think that's what he's going
to do i don't think he likes b6 because
a5
gets played um he would play b6 maybe if
there was no other
or second a pawn but here he just takes
it says look
knight c5 i'm always capturing meanwhile
i got g4 coming and i don't really care
about
any of the puns and queen b8 check king
d7 there's nothing special about that
it just looks like it should be good for
white but here comes black attack
and yeah you played h3 you're opening up
more lines exactly what we were talking
about
here rook takes g4 the h file is open
the g file
is going to be pressure on the g2 square
though that knight on f4 that's really a
heroic piece because it defends the pawn
and also at some point the e6 pawn could
feel quite loose
yeah i'm trying to trying to think what
do i do next as white
that's the that's the issue that i'm
having
yeah knight takes g2 is suddenly a
threat because they're you just kind of
sacrifice a bunch of ps in the queen g6
at the end the knight md3 is loose
the king is out in the open so i would
not want to allow that that's for sure
yeah knight g2 take everything queen g6
and all of a sudden
we have this position where like all of
danny's pieces are on the queen side
there's nothing going on over there and
you can play queen f7
or you can take on g2 as i think knight
g2 is
the the way to go bishop h6 is where you
kind of forget that you need that guy to
stop knight c5 so
don't be doing that you know actually
you said bishop h6
wait that actually looks good and you
said you finished your sentence of
wait you need to cover the c5 square
yeah very good call and that's exactly
how
the brain would work too it's like okay
bishop h6 looks normal but lawrence
he seems to be finding everything he
needs to find this might not be the best
engine move but i love it
yeah it looks very good to me and i
don't even see a way for white to
fend this position off because your
king's out in the f file in the open
there's a rook on g4 there's a queen
coming into the game here rook takes g2
i
yeah this is exactly what's on queen g6
takes d3 and
now that you've taken the knight on d3
now you can move that dark square bishop
and you should because that rook from d8
wants to go to f8 g8 or h2 i'm not even
sure
which square it's going to it depends on
where the king goes but king h1 there's
bishop b4 for example
just look at this king there's nothing
within like a 4x4 box of it like
this is ridiculous so so exposed here
um danny's king's just gonna get hunted
down by the pieces and
don't forget please down a minute on the
clock as well this is just
all going wrong for danny in in this
match as it's becoming more and more
clear that
lawrence is just playing fast
comfortable he might not be getting the
best positions but
the they're ones where danny is not able
to prosecute the advantage
yeah i mean look at this kingdom on the
open you should probably play king e1
king d1 king c1 and just
run your king to where you have pieces
but it's a position where it's actually
even except for the fact that white has
a rook and black has a bishop
but the rooks are not actually helpful
right now you have the open b file
that's great
yeah but it's not leaving the checkmate
on the other side the king on f2 here's
bishop h4
check ffa check yeah
this is over he wants bishop there and
queen f3 but
brook or sorry bishop h4 first
followed by the rook getting involved is
going to lead to me
somewhere oh that'll do it
and we have time for one more game it
looks like there's 10 seconds left
yep so this will be officially
the last game in the uh the three minute
time control and
at this point it's like if if danny
loses another game
it's not only the demoralizing feeling
of going into a break on the loss but
just that the lead is going to be so
insurmountable it's going to be eight
points at that point and that just feels
like too much
and finally we have seen this knight fd2
move i mean we saw it once before but
taking advantage of the fact that bishop
on b7 is not defended
yeah this position opening up black's
king in the center
now hang on a sec this is different than
last time yeah bishop h3 probably could
have played there
well it's just that wasn't he castled
last time how did he like steal a move
there
oh yeah how did he what's this oh
did the rook go to e1 i think for lauren
so instead of playing rook e1
he immediately played knight f3 to d2
right which is yeah there we go that was
it that's much better
um okay that makes sense i'm taking this
bishop on f4 if i'm danny i'm down
seven points i'm taking on f4 and asking
questions later
yeah that's very reasonable just go
follow up with bishop d6
knight d7 because now i think he could
even play bishop e5
f4 just kind of chuck that bishop into
e5
brook takes out four if it's their next
move is definitely a consideration
yeah okay still there
if it's there one more turn it's a
consideration
now's the time right no oh okay he's not
doing it but now the bishop comes to e5
just like you were saying and that's a
pain
yeah both bishops look good here for
white
uh
this is solid just solid for uh
for lawrence here comes f4 yeah not even
necessary at the moment but right
exactly what i said you don't even need
it yet
in the rook c2 rookie that's a pretty
classy uh
rook lift by lawrence just a double
works in the e file
so he sees that that's where he wants i
like
bishop c8 yeah bishop c8 looks
reasonable
and then you trade and play rookie too i
guess yeah
no this is this is comfortable for for
lawrence like eval might be
equal-ish but um let's be fair this this
is easy to play for white i love the
rook c2 rook e2 idea danny's uh giving
up on trying to remove that bishop he
says all right that's that's yours
yeah and now the e file bishop c7
i was about to ask you is there some
bishop c7 you just wouldn't exchange
oof okay he dropped it back
and white is still doing great you have
control of the only fully open file
the bishop on f4 better than the
counterpart in f8 the bishop on b7 way
worse than bishop one h3 queen e6 check
there's like queen e6 queen f7 can i
just bring my pieces in and
yeah all the time
there's no the queensland bishop c
bishop c7
oh my goodness bishop c7 oh he's just
walked into it oh gosh
yeah oh so laurence has
missed his fair share of wins in this
game so far
yeah and he's still winning
[Laughter]
well you know you have the active pieces
here it's a queen on f7 or rook on e6
and you just look at the pieces one by
one probably the only
about equal pieces of the knight on f6
and the knight in c3
otherwise all of white's pieces are
dominating
yep someone in the
chess.com game chat just said that
lawrence is on danny like a cheap suit
oh gosh night g8 oh man
danny's really setting up the board here
for uh for the one minute portion this
is not a good look
there's gonna be some puzzle rush win
here somewhere yeah it's like
is there going to be some h4h5h6 then
is it that is it knight e2 knight
i like knight e2 knight f4 and then you
know
there's gonna be some dirty stuff there
that actually looks great can you stop
that 92 and a 4 queen each five minutes
i don't think so knight f4 is gonna be
like there's not a single move that
makes a threat rook's
trapped queen's more or less trapped c5
knight f4 and lawrence knows there's
going to be just a ko here
yeah c takes d4 you're rook finally
doing something on the open line but
as you're talking about knight g6 or
even just knight h5 going for the g7
pawn that should
do the trick queen g5 i can get behind
that
so the knight can move with his queen c
one checking all that stuff oh
okay trading rooks i see the
and then queen e7 maybe yeah and even if
you lose the d5 pawn at some point it's
worth it
but i was just looking at the yeah the
bar and it went down
quite a lot there i don't know why
maybe bishop e7 that looks
reasonable even pontig's d4 i guess is
playable here
just to uh yeah the bishop one e5 is not
defended very well
yeah that's i think that's a good move
that must be
that must be the vibe because then you
go bishop c5 if he takes back
right that's definitely it yep
danny locates that one and will we see
lawrence getting punished for
not putting this game away bishop c5 go
go go
yeah because otherwise bishop 96 when
the g7 pawn would have been
a disaster so bishop c5 says okay we're
forcing the bishops off the board then
this d-pawn
can try to become a pass pawn uh then i
like it white should have an easy time
making sure that pawn's blockaded that's
a i don't know how danny turned that
around it's pretty impressive
yeah it looks just completely lost and
now it's like wait
there's still life absolutely
so even taking a knight f6 is you know
one way to go probably not the best but
hey hey everything's defended and when
you get closer to an end game you
especially when the queens are on you
stop viewing the d-pawn like an isolated
pawn you start viewing it as a pass pawn
completely agree and look at that move
good move by lawrence try and trade
queen so the king could then
go to the d4 square blockade the pawn of
course your king can't go and block hit
upon when they're
queen's on the board it's too dangerous
i like the way lawrence is playing this
now though yeah he's really doing
doing this well how do you even
stop g5 i think you gotta go like for
other you know queen
i don't know what the move would be you
gotta get some counter play going
queen c6 or so he goes queen d6 probably
some knight e4 idea 94 now
okay 97 yeah
four seconds and like it's safe to say
that danny shouldn't be winning this
game
no so he's just trying to survive
so b3 knight c1 typical plan to win back
upon so
oh he's gonna have to check back it's
just
b3 knight c1 that's the idea
how do you deal with that actually yeah
you might have to just
go for the kingside pawns
so flaming like f5 check or something
and try to
yeah see what he does because if king e5
i think king to h5 and g6 is too quick
so he has to go back
so i like starting with f5 that's a
really good point because it looks like
you're putting the pawn on loose squares
but as you're
suggesting the white king was run in and
look at this
i think he says look i'm i'm up in the
you know i don't mind a draw
going into the next portion keep my lead
no point in like
playing f5 maybe and then going on to
lose somehow to some outside eight pawns
so
i let's just say i i understand from a
gamesmanship
perspective what lawrence was up to
there yeah he's just
maintaining the lead the worst thing you
can do is lose that game whether it's a
six
point gap and danny can try to win all
his bullet games but it is seven points
lawrence trent out to a huge lead we
will have
bullet remaining is there any chance for
danny what do you think can he
win seven games in a row in bullet is
there even time for that
well yeah i think the first question is
is there a chance for danny
mathematically that's i think where you
have to start because
um if there is a chance for danny
mathematically then you start about how
credible it would be
for that to actually happen and in the
bullet i think if i was
you know having a match go this way the
number one thing i'd want to do
is go play bullet so this might be the
you know
the only chance for danny but um
honestly uh i
i don't think so uh the way the match is
going i gotta give full credit to
lawrence trent for
the way he's played so far he's played
quick he's played controlled so unless
we see
just like some sort of horrendous
version of lawrence trent
in bullet i think he's got this match
robert yeah i have to agree and i would
say that
just to reiterate what you're saying
that even in the positions that were
objectively bad for lawrence
it wasn't a clear knockout for danny he
started burning clock and lawrence
started playing great defense to survive
so
it's going to be uphill task doesn't
come close
to covering what it will have to be for
dan to win this but we will take a quick
break and when we return we'll come back
for the bullet segment of this i'm not
gm speeches championship
and as we return for the conclusion of
this i am not gm speech has championship
match
should we want to give a shout out to dr
wolf who provides very friendly personal
coaching for those
who are have ios download it for free
it's a great tool to help you improve on
your chest
personalized coaching is generally
speaking a very beneficial thing so
definitely get on that use dr wolf and
oman i think that danny needs to turn
into a wolf right now because
he needs to win every single game and
there's not even room for a single draw
no that's the way it feels right now i
might have to get danny on the dr wolf
app as well
for some quick time pep talk but
uh it is uh drawing dead uh for
he's drawing dead he needs to win as you
said every game it feels like if he
draws
loses maybe it's mathematically possible
but he's gonna have to be like meeting
trent in
like 20 moves in some games so uh if
if we get these long drawn out games
opposite bishops
stuff like that it's not going to favor
danny who needs to be
cognizant of the clock um as we
mentioned it's not about whether danny
can win seven games
it's whether seven games are actually
going to fit into this time control
which is as you said only 25 minutes
yeah one single 75 move game and all of
a sudden you're
might be out of time so danny goes to d4
i was thinking he might do this but he's
done it a bit too late
considering uh you know the score but he
got good
positions against the french it wasn't
really the first move that did him in
and here
we have a london system and i mean
the sad part is his position is already
better okay by the way i love this
position
um is this just already better than like
everything that i've seen this match
yeah it's easy to play for white and now
look at him going
super aggressive on the king side i'm
not sure it's justified just yet black
can just
park a pony on e4 and say where's your
attack coming from but
yeah yeah wow um i don't mind b5 from
from lawrence uh my concern for danny is
that the knight on e4 just like can't be
removed it's so annoying
um oh takes the knight g5 yeah
i saw the eval bar go crazy too just
knight takes f7 just
still still still again again
again although what he's doing is he
seems perfectly good for white right now
he's just saying please take me on g5
i'll take with the f pawn i'm going to
crash through on the king side anyway so
oh f6 just take on e6 like you don't
care yeah i
felt like that's what danny was gonna do
um where was this type of conviction in
the other formats
yeah he has just planted his knight on
e6
and what's happening capturing e4 f5 as
possible but i think he wanted knight c5
but he's hanging and just and not people
not realize there's a night hang in
there
yeah that knight could have been
captured and should have been captured
because nobody
runs away queen b5 though and
c or b3 okay maybe a bit more solid of
an approach but i like what lawrence is
doing he's trying to strike on the queen
side
and what does white do now rook h to e1
that has to be the move right
whoa oh not a fan not a fan of that move
ah but force force galore and after
knight c there's knight b6 coming
yeah take it it's like they don't
realize pieces are hanging
take that guy on c8 they're just so
important
yeah they're no still hanging what's
queen a7 now like he's getting mated
yeah that turned pretty quick queen b2
only moves and then rook c6 rook
a6 oh gosh that's painful
okay they're not focusing all their
attention to the king side
they play on one side of the board only
it's like all right we're going to the
queen side lords a couple moves here
back to the other side
oh didn't like that knight takes c8 nope
what yeah this is gonna be a problem
with a knight lands there
the knight is more valuable than a rook
so i would not be taking the roof on d1
i would have played d5 there oh
wait seven yeah say the same thing
rook's coming to e7
i would have taken the rook on b2
because he's gonna take b2 with check no
he's not
what is happening here knight e5 just i
can't even do it
he doesn't though rook takes b2 a check
and
wait what's happening knight is on e5
he's gonna meet him
is white winning this oh it's winning
yes
take it and then you're saying
what just happened oh my gosh
what was that guys we need to see this
danny
in every game from now on just every
game
this danny needs to show up seriously
what was that
and danny learned his lesson by the way
because he didn't put his night on e4
until um either lauren food is rook or
castle he looked at this yeah yes he
clearly did and
this is and he played d5 rather than f5
so some changes in danny's approach
f5 now makes sense just to protect the
pawn on e4 and yeah
i still can't get over that checkmate on
f7 that's hilarious
that is hilarious because he could have
gone to f8 as well
right like he chose to go in the corner
and then it just presented itself and
this position for danny can't can't
complain no
certainly not if you need a win i mean
at least the c4 pawn's under attack the
bishop one f6 looks good
even if white objectively is doing well
here take out your c3 maybe take c3
queen e8 type of stuff
yeah i love that love that
oh actually can you just take and take
on d5 you just win the pawn directly
i think you could take on d5 and rook d1
then maybe queen e8
yeah and so now he's having pawn has the
c4 square
for his knight but i like that d4 square
for lawrence's bishop
yeah now there's no queen eight no queen
d7 i think you almost got to go like
f4 or queen g5 yeah that makes sense
he takes in c5 but that's just gonna be
recaptured and
all right he's trying to trade off
pieces he is up a pawn so that's
understandable
now that looks like a strong move to me
that looks like a very annoying move to
face
so 95 i looked at the uh
you know our live screen here and the
evaluation bar went down so that meant
is probably winning yeah because the
queen can't move from d8 so it would
have to be a move like
95 but it wasn't played that this looks
very good for for white i would say and
maybe
e4 bishop takes g7 for q7 yeah that's
the tactic
didn't see it's a knight d6 maybe six
probably is the movie but c5
also looks reasonable and can't play
rook b8 that's the problem the knight
oh that's annoying
oh i like this though oh hang on i don't
like this though
it can't go to c it's close though
i liked this though okay so going after
f3
so d4 oh d4 it
was also gonna
bishop uh chills on d4s really nicely
yeah and the a7 pawns undertake g7 now
h7
can be captured yeah nice nice it's
could be a mating net
yep king to h5 oh rook a8 oh he could
take on b6 and take on c3 as well you
know he could have uh
captured that but rook 8 is more
principled i would say
so king no don't make a draw i think
he's going to yeah because king g6
rook jack king wait a minute why didn't
he do that
he could have run his teammate file yeah
what
yeah that would have been better for
sure the the miscalculation that i had
in my head was like oh king h5 rook
takes h7
but that would never be possible yeah
and all right danny going back to his d4
opening and has expanded the center
lauren's trying to undermine white
center with pieces right now hitting it
on f3
if the knight moves from f6 the d4 pawn
is going to be under attack so knight
can go f6 to d7 was a possibility and
said
he goes like this and well i'm on it
seems like white has a very nice
position
at the opening yeah i would say so i
think
i think that uh lawrence is not going to
be unhappy like sometimes you take these
positions in bullet with black and
they're just
so quick and easy to play that's true so
you give up sort of the
objective value in terms of like purely
neutralizing the position for
ease of play and that way you can
conserve your time
definitely that's a big big dislike on
that move
yeah because now it's gonna be good
night against questionable bishop
queen h4 queen f4 yeah keep keep the
queens for sure
but look at that knight on e5 just can't
kick that one out
h4 time for h4 yeah he does it h5 h6
queen of six
uh lawrence closing out closing
everything
yeah do you want you want to play a5 the
queen comes to c5 so i'm going to take
over the c file
yeah up to you i want to play queen f6
and like well if you do it now you
actually drop the g
pawn funny enough good to note that the
queen on b6
pins that pawn so it goes king g2 can
you get g4 to happen that's what white
desperately needs to wow and
lawrence is doing the pragmatic thing i
think he's going to go like a5
kng7 queen f6 which is so annoying to
play against
and i think that white's objectively
lost even objectively lost
and objectively going to play like a
three-minute game here
yeah and so i think danny needs to
somehow come up with an attack but
there's none to speak of none rook on e1
at least
get the at least get the rook operating
and look at this he could have taken b3
he just puts his rook on queen at c7
keeping everything closed
bishop c2 okay gotta be bishop c2
yeah here comes queen c5 knight g4 is
now a threat no
no brutal oh if you didn't see knight g4
he's gonna find it now
yeah and there's almost queen e4 and c2
but
too fancy too fancy night age two
checkups oh
that might be the the dagger in this
match with 16 minutes left you got to
feel that
that danny needed that after a draw and
a loss consecutive
that that's just not enough and danny's
opening here is
hot garbage as they say well it looks
like a french
that lawrence was playing throughout the
match and yeah this is
really bad even queen h5 taking over
this
king side can't recommend
no steer clear
um so there's gonna be a sacrifice in e6
potentially available
does it work i think so takes queen e7
take knight d5 bishop g5
looks looked crushing yeah
but okay lawrence is not looking to take
risks
i think at this point but i like black's
position now because if you can just
chisel that white center you're probably
just losing a pawn as white
yeah he's very losing a pawn but these
often backfire you just
chuck things like f4 next after g5
the bishop one g7 not being protected is
huge you're right g5 f4 and
can't take it without losing material
because white just
you know chucks that bishop out of the
way rookie won and
it's so easy to play this and bullet
with white a big fan of
what lawrence is doing he just didn't
care one bit about that on e5
yeah you kind of trick your opponent in
a way because taking on d4 take on e5
looked very nice winning material
but actually the pressure and the build
up was good for black so probably taking
on d4 was a big mistake in
einstein just bishop
i don't know e2 or d3
knight c5 makes sense to me oh he's
gonna take it
and he might even go queen yeah i was
gonna say queen c7 queen d6 stops
castling makes a lot of sense
okay so queen e7 mate is a threat bishop
oh
wait good move i think i would take on
c6 and
just and long castle yeah maybe okay
queen g7 is very
pragmatic though okay so black's up a
pawn right
yes black is up one pawn here he's got
the bishop pair i mean
definitely a fantastic position he's
solved everything from the opening
he's got 19 seconds but i mean a bullet
i think he's still got a lot of time
relatively speaking e5 winning a piece
no it was knight h5 okay
so that was a little tactic that
lawrence yeah he would go in there
anyway
but somehow this doesn't feel very easy
for black people
what's danny's knight doing on b7 by the
way it's hanging out
he really put it there on purpose i
don't know what it's doing
too yeah i got nothing
[Music]
but now it's there there it is a very
useful square
so e3 yeah b3 to take away the c4 square
that makes perfect sense
instead lawrence is going on the h file
trying to win this h6 bomb
yep okay that knight has taken a journey
by the way and a pretty successful one
knight e5 b3 for white b3
b3 looks completely reasonable 93 okay
the g2 point is underneath
four oh this oh no that's
that's bad this is a catastrophe the 93
is actually trapped so
and the knight on d4 is so strong yeah
this is this is gg
that's a shame right there your knight
is trapped on e3 still
even after all these trays that's insane
by the way yes
knight c6 all winning the knight was
able to trade himself off but even still
what black
takes f7 fancy that would be a great way
to take advantage of a pre-move right
because
expecting night of seven supreme bishop
takes that would have been really cool
there's richie one there but yeah i feel
like the pre-move is
worth an attempt i think so in terms of
expected value from that position i'm
with you
poor danny this is this is going to be a
loss because those rook end games are
the worst to play as well
yeah because they take forever right you
not only are you losing but
yeah yeah there's a resolution danny's
yeah gonna throw in the towel on that
one
and we actually see the ratings evening
out in in bullet
so whatever they started with they're
pretty much identical now
and here we finally at long last have a
scotch
and is is d take c6 bishop d3 some
pre-move stuff
because is danny getting mated here
queen h4 knight takes h2 i mean i just
queen g3
whoa queen g3 is winning
on the spot yep
hmm do you think yeah maybe he went d
takes c6
hoping for some kind of pre-move because
dc6 you just trade the queens feels like
you have just like a way better berlin
or something
yeah so this is is it danny's turn for
the attack knight e4
etc etc yeah here it comes careful of
bishop h3 but i think queen f3 will be
played
yeah queen of three looks good and then
f5 is coming there's queen
oh because the queen one check yeah
queen e1 it's good move by danny there
yes that f6 check we'll pick up the
bishop on f5 for the night but
black can just start capturing so not
too
scary yeah this is
a clean exchange up for black yeah
still bishop d3 you can kind of plug the
d file a bit
yeah but now that the position is
opening up even more the rooks have
the d file the e5 and now
yikes yeah this is not going to cut it
here for
uh mr wrench no it certainly will not
and it's one of these situations i'm on
where there are 10 minutes left in the
match and you're just like
i don't want to play anymore yeah i've
lost
right bishop coming to d6
okay rook some d7 of counterplay bishop
d6 as you said rookie one checkmate
coming
right next
g3 g5 oh yep
a piece that's a piece and lawrence is
higher rated in bullet and
honestly what i thought was going to be
one of the closest matches
is extremely not one of the closest
matches it could be one of the biggest
blowouts
yeah just one of those days right where
if you started this match
tomorrow and just said okay clean slate
it would very likely be much closer or
it could even be a
blood and danny's favor so it's credit
to lawrence for sure he's played a
really
energetic and strong match i i have been
really surprised pleasantly so about his
defensive tenacity like there were those
positions where he
uh ended up casting queen side and was
in danger
but he was able to stave off the attack
while creating attacks of his own so the
the way he was able to obtain counter
play throughout this entire match has
been
really awesome to see yeah and that's
just uh
he has to be a good defender i think
with his style when you play that the
sort of intuitive quick uh
moves quick style of chess you have to
be a pretty good defender because
you will miss things from time to time
playing as quick as he is
oh queen c6 won the house there
yeah dude this wins oh i don't even know
if you want to take that pawn p2 because
d6
f6 would check so you might have to take
this knight on e4 but then the queen
centralizes so yeah queen takes c6
missed opportunity there
okay checking a5 seems weird king f1 or
c3 even he wants c6
queen d5 choose trey taking on d4 king
d2 and isn't white
kind of up a pawn because black's pawn
is doubled on h file
and white's pawn is a potential passer
on the b
file yep
the virtue six was nice right because
you just say if you're ever going to
trade me
you're undoubling my pawns on that side
of the board
yeah i don't think he'll bite on that
rook a3 by white though it looks like a
great option
oh yeah actually gate three looked
almost winning it probably was
right there was really nice just full
board awareness by man saying
the rook on g3 yeah it's great i'm
fighting for an open final rook to b3
for instance
g3 to b3 or now rook g through to a3
that could just
now he sees it now he sees it
there it is and two connected pass bonds
over there
is going to be two connected pass bonds
too many
yeah you're not even winning a pawn back
for black that's oh no
now the king maybe goes and helps out
these pawns
yeah king f3 king g4 also comes to mind
if you want to steal the spawn h4
yeah he needs to play rook h1 danny he's
not actually
catch one right now which one danny
there you go take it you know
oh and now d4 is in trouble wait how
many pawns do you just give up
yeah he i still think white wins this
but um
we'll see h2
oh okay rook ooh hang on f4 f4 i need f4
okay good move yeah now you're too slow
and the rook's gobbling all the pawns up
take on h7
it's tragic yeah even when every game
he was coming back just didn't work
that story of most people's chest crew
oh it looked good and then it
didn't work yeah no it's true
and here we have these pawns on b5 and
a6 and
it's actually a reasonable opening at
this stage it looks
not so bad for black but you're giving
up central control for
some kind of pressure with your queen
side pawns but
yeah that's just maybe four ideas
six minutes plus
even if it's a win for danny in this
game far too little
and far too late definitely
definitely too little too late here and
we've been talking about how
oh knight d4 uh nice
i was good as i was about to compliment
uh lawrence's uh
you know tactics and defensive skills
there he finds another one
taking advantage of the king and queen
being on the same diagonal
and he's tried this but i feel like
when white stops that h3 thread that if
you
okay take and see that's really smart
because yeah i didn't like the look of
that knight getting to e4 at some point
rook takes c3 with rook takes h3 ideas
oh gosh this might happen
you take twice on b5 and rook takes h3
mate
oh man he sees it now he sees it now
yeah maybe queen ooh queen c6
still hoping for bishops he wants it he
wants it bad
can white try f5 maybe and you know go
for an attack on zone okay bishop e4
oh oh look at that queen f2
that was true oh no but the meat is oh
it's not me not me because the
queen blocks the diagonal
maybe takes and rook g3 next oh that's
just
yeah it doesn't you're a a mon
it's a draw yeah yeah it's a draw but
you get to make the other guy
suffer it's like oh you got a queen and
a rook who cares buddy
yep and brooke oh and rook f2 by the way
was the only draw
that's actually crazy because i thought
you could move your work anywhere but
then white plays rook f3
to give up the rook to give the sp space
of the king along the first rank
a cheeky draw yeah for
and b3 now here come the b-pawn
movements
i caught a little uh a little danny
smirk
half chuckle at the uh at the draw there
so
you know he's he sort of admitted to
himself that we've hit the end of the
line here
the the match is going to go to to
lawrence although it may have been
mathematically clear a while ago
it feels like it just became evident to
these to these guys
yep and look at this queen d5 wins on
the spot for black right
well there's a there's one for danny
robert yeah we got one
you know it does probably feel a little
bit better to get a couple wins down the
stretch
because it seems like there will be time
for
at least one more game after this one
maybe two and if you can
cut into the gap you feel at least like
okay i didn't lose by
12 points i lost by seven it's
not really much in terms of consolation
but all right you'll take it
yeah you don't want to be the biggest
blowout of the event so he's trying to
give other people a chance to
earn that title indeed
and okay well knight at five queen e4
check go for the maid
yup knight f5 is a good way to start
just stopping queen e3
as a resource to block
okay king the king's run to c1 survive
yep
he lives queen e1 might be the only room
still down a piece so you know even
though you're not checkmating
should be sufficient here oh god knight
d4
yeah the knight into e2 i like that
oh brutal position
queen c1 just a5
yeah time for a5 where's the checkmates
i'm kind of sack on b3 coming
right now take it
yeah you crashed through nice
that's well that's maiden yeah okay you
can sack the queen
true and now it's an extra queen so i
don't think we really need to come to
too much on uh the current position
hopefully we don't
yeah five extra pawns and a queen for
rook that's
i think uh danny can handle this one
yep no more tricks up lawrence's sleeve
and this one here
and that leaves us time for just one
more game after it
yeah most likely one more game um
shouldn't be more some free moves there
yeah and well
cutting the deficit to nine
lawrence
and that'll that'll be a win for danny
there let's see if he can get his 2600
back
and higher rated i was gonna say that
right if he wins this game he ends up
with a higher bullet rating
yeah that's that's about as much of a
win as danny can take from this match
right here
yeah there's definitely some hang and
stuff like take and take on h8 at this
point
i don't think either guy knows or cares
what they're doing
now moving the pieces around trying to
have a good laugh
yeah and oh this looks
terrible for black knight h5
queen takes d5 that knight is coming to
f5 or h5 i'm not sure which is better
but both
will be available bishop takes a g5
just castle yeah bring the knight to d6
knight e4 with tempo okay or f5 same
idea
agreed
maybe danny can get a nice puzzle rush
mate in here somewhere it feels like
it's close
well that's a free very free piece and
we might get another game
oh my gosh one more queen eight check
and then queen takes f7 yeah
i think he wants the match to end yeah
don't blame him no not even a little bit
13 12 11. it's the countdown
yeah danny did he wants another game is
he going to get it five seconds
i think he he's looking at the clock
he's like i don't want any more
no i i oh
this one doesn't count right i don't
think so f3 no
no okay the kings are coming out boys
yeah these kings are coming out i guess
there are lines to
continue
and well well the worst part is if
lawrence wins then he's higher rated
today
you know it's not that bad for white
right now it's looking pretty good
paul's coming to g4 and then i guess the
g3 is some attack for white on the
king side it's the bong clap
yeah now it looks pretty bad again
there's there's no more fitting way to
finish
uh robert this match than this opening
right here how did we get from what
should have been a tactical position to
some kind of like strategic one now
yeah now it's like two bishops versus
the you know the double pawns and
whatever
oh that was good yeah bishop h4 check
coming
okay de2 and bishop h4 just please
please
even if you go go d2 and just take the
queen back it also
looks good right damn
doesn't look so bad either
oh it's miss chances this is not the
vibe
no no this is hey a
good little in-between move there with
rook a to b i like that
bishop back to c3 bishop c5 coming for
black
okay bishop i think bishop c5 would have
stolen the b2 pawn with check
yeah king e3 rook d2 bishop b4 here
bishop before this b4 is really nice
yeah now it's like king e3 and he's got
this little formation
although he has to watch g6 knight d6
takes takes rookie eight
yep so nice to retreat somewhere to
maybe g3 and then bishop
i'm still looking at bishop c5 i feel
like trading the bishops is
going to be good for black the pawn on
d3 is somehow
untouchable yeah it's this weird
weird position we got here rook c2
okay so knight h1 to f2 like the only oh
i don't like the knight there
it doesn't really help you
so what now bishop e7 yep
just bishop d8 bishop a5 oh that looks
good too
there's some bishop e1 stuff as well
yeah that's some weirdness
okay so now you can get d4 in that
should help somehow i don't really know
exactly how it helps but rook d4 is all
knight f5
rook f4 knight d5 oh oh oh oh
no it's tragic it's tragic for danny
yeah now that knight's just jumping
everywhere lawrence basically has a
position where
the knight jumps are all he needs
for sure knight d8 or knight e8 to d6
too many night jumps oh there's another
pack here
there's no good discover check that was
like you know
perfectly take the knight take enough
six
you have chance there oh that's maybe
seven oh
that's very meaty yeah can't even go
rook g1 because the bishop covers
that e5 doesn't even do anything
it protects the g7 square except for the
fact that knight's already there
well that's that come on we uh
see the match finally come to a close
and
lawrence trent wins it by the score of
17 and a half eight and a half and nine
point spread
what a match it was by lawrence yeah we
really got to take uh
a moment and give the the full credit to
lawrence here
um we could we could say that you know
some of it's on danny for
missing his chances but i feel like
lawrence came in with a game plan
um he started out really well or she
said at the very beginning he
maybe was a little sluggish but he
really found his rhythm and he found the
ways
that he could take points off danny
whether it was using the clock getting
up on time
taking him into positions where
objectively might have the worst
evaluation
but he knows the ideas uh well enough to
play it in blitz so
i thought he came in with the game plan
he executed it um
but you have to put a little bit of that
uh blame onto
danny for missing his chances and most
importantly when things were looking
tough and he got his one chance
he didn't even convert it yep i concur
and we are going to go to a break and
when we return we will have both players
for the post match interview
so lawrence and danny will join me and
amman so stay tuned everybody we will be
right back with the post match
interviews
and we return with both players danny
our apologies the matching go to your
way and lawrence a big congratulations
because
you know you were off to a bit of a
tough start at the first break you were
down two to one
what did you change what did you tell
yourself that allowed you to go on a
really big winning streak after that
um nothing particularly i i was quite
happy with how the french went and i
thought i'd keep on doing
that obviously my english experiment uh
was exactly that it was an experiment so
when i switched that up
i got a bit more stability with white
but i just thought as long
as danny isn't punishing me when he has
white
then i'm you know i'm i'm gonna have a
very good chance in the match
and yeah i i think we both played pretty
badly actually today to realist i think
in general the level was quite poor um
i just managed to you know
convert more positions swindle in a
couple of spots as well
which always makes quite the difference
and um
yeah i i i guess i probably deserved the
match overall but it was
i think the score flatters my uh
my my level of play i i don't think the
margin was as wide as that so
obviously you know commiserations to my
boy danny
um yeah i don't know what what else to
say i think you're giving yourself
enough credit i mean you picked this
french line
which you said just now off the before
we were with these
guys that you specifically prepared it
for the match and i had no idea what to
do against it and and then i looked at
the line briefly at the break
and even though i objectively knew like
white was getting good positions like
from a practical perspective you made a
very good choice
and the fact that you like completely
punished me with the french
will go down and and the list and the
list of the greatest
the greatest embarrassments of my life
um
and so um you you were the better player
today you prepared you prepared and made
it made a very good choice and so don't
don't
don't sell yourself too short man i
think you played really well
thank you no i i mean yeah i just uh i
don't even know how i came across this
line as many people know follow me i'm
not a french player at all
um trying to find something and you
played this
you know this scotch and everything yeah
i don't know i wasn't even going to play
the scotch by the way i really could
yeah okay
i was i was gonna place it but it didn't
matter i mean i i i admit that i
i did not put the level of preparation
you did with an opening choice like that
which just
i mean i feel like you you won the match
right there on a practical level because
even though i started off on the right
foot
i yeah i couldn't i couldn't figure this
out and even when i was getting good
positions i wasn't comfortable i was i
was constant or time pressure
it was frustrating honestly and then
about midway through the three minute i
just like
i was just i was just really really down
with how i was playing so but you uh you
kept your foot on the gas
and then i was then i was toast
well yeah i i guess i just
managed to convert and yeah the yeah i
think as you said danny you should have
probably switched it up yeah yeah
and then i think it would have been a
bit more competitive but yeah because in
the end
danny you actually ended up trying just
about every white opening in the book
and yeah you had some e4 games some d4
games and it seemed like once you
started switching it up
the positions got a little better but
you were stubborn with uh with
trying to beat down the french and i
think that was something that you uh you
didn't want to give up is that right
like you felt like you had to beat the
french
rather than then avoid it 100 i'm
nothing if i'm not a man
of faulty principles and so i when he
was playing the french i was like
robert's never going to let me hear the
end of this crap
i was like i got it for you i said on
air i was like screw robert
sitting there telling me that i can't
beat the french and damn it he was right
so you know that's what was going on in
my head
yeah we figured and i mean lawrence on
your end
right you took a lead at four to three
and you had
just enough time left for a final game
in that five minute portion
and then danny end up hanging upon with
this bishop takes h7 check tactic
but i'm just curious what made you
switch your opening
in that game was the fact that you took
a lead and wanted to play something more
solid
or what was going through your mind i
was playing this nonsense g4 english
that
some norwegian guy tried a couple of
times
um you know basically never trust that
guy
uh yeah yeah the whack and
uh yeah i and then i was he
he played this bishop take he didn't
take on d2 and i was like god i haven't
prepared that
what an idiot and i was just getting
really whack positions which suited
danny's style and he was just beating me
and i just thought
you know what i'm stubborn enough with
my stock market positions
i think it's time to switch it up and
you know cut the losers as they say
cut the losers quick let the winners
so we had to give that garbage up and
then we'd switch to something which i
also looked at
uh this uh queen's indian and which is
solid and you know
you get decent positions which actually
don't think suit danny particularly
um so i think that was probably the best
decision i made in the match was just
been in that
daft english very very well
yeah well it was it was tough
it was tough for me i got to be honest
it was uh yeah and it's one of those
things where like i guess i i shouldn't
expect much better
like i mean i'm not it's like one of
those things where you hold yourself to
a standard of what you think you're
capable of and then all of a sudden you
get over the head with hey you're not as
good as you think you are
and matches like this just like
humiliate you so it was it was
frustrating i mean i felt
and then i and then i felt like i
couldn't gather myself like mentally
when it started to get away from me like
that's just the honest truth like i
couldn't
and and like you said i think i just
should i should have gone away from the
french earlier
and and probably it's a different match
then but yeah
you know you get all the credit man i
mean that was like and i also think even
in the time scrambles you were just
better
i mean like i i was i was nervous and i
was getting under time pressure and i
couldn't i couldn't quite find it today
so i mean i you know that's kind of my
thing i know i'm answering questions
before robert and amanda answered
asked me but i just just sitting here in
my head like why did i why did i suck
so bad today like that's the only
question like robert and aman should
legitimately be asking me
like why did you suck so bad today and i
can't figure it out
other than i give you credit that you
really threw me off my game
so that's kind of the honest truth well
you may have lacked some
highlights uh today danny but you had
one good one you had one
smothered mate knight f7 mate in an
absolutely insane game
i nearly fell off my chair there because
as soon as you as soon as you allowed
rook g7 king h8 and i played 96
like i perked up in my chair i was like
i don't see how he's winning it right
away
so and maybe there was even a mate for
you on the board like there probably was
like
i'll be honest with you i didn't even
see knight f7 was yeah i just thought
you were making moves
yeah do i take the queen what do i do no
i just i didn't even see the mate and i
nearly fell off my chair
luckily already uh i had such a margin
that's the sort of game by the way where
if greg shahadi is watching
oh gosh you know that's the sort of game
that greg
would win against me he'd swindle me but
there would be like a two point gap and
then i would go on monkey tilt and
i would just blast off the next few
games and he would win
so that's how greg does it but i just
got lucky
shout out to greg if you're watching
buddy i just got lucky that
um i had such a big lead in points today
yeah well lawrence as someone who has
you know
unfortunately or i can say i i empathize
when people make fun of you like not
beating magnus up a rook and things like
that like today i wear the face of shame
and failure
and today you are the victor so i'm just
glad to be like you know
just the the guy that just i feel like i
i really hit the bottom of the barrel
today
so you know we all have our bad days i
mean derek henry run
40 yards today so i mean what's he paid
millions for if he can
run during this broadcast you tell me
yeah
well you know i feel like i feel like
the next time you and i throw down
we're definitely gonna have to have
banter you know because oh yeah
then at the very least if i'm getting my
ass kicked which i think i can say
i'm a player today so i have to worry
about it um then the very least i can
get some good one-liners in there so
that's true i i'm up for that and uh
yeah yeah just
yeah obviously happy to to win a match
it's been a long time since i've won
didn't you get out of the first round
last year in this event
oh maybe i won the uh yeah definitely
did
you die yeah you won yeah i think i won
the first and then i played john
bartholomew in the second
oh yeah yeah so um
yeah well thanks for making our life
very easy because the mom and i yeah
we didn't really prepare questions you
but you answered all the questions we
should have asked
so what you're doing you're dealing with
chess commentators you know
lawrence and i are our chess
commentators not just players but uh
that's correct i just like i said i said
the only question you can legitimately
ask me is like danny
why'd you suck so bad and lawrence like
you know what was your what was your
approach and he obviously
kind of explained it and he crushed it
so you know um
anyway man i don't have much else to say
unless you guys have more questions
well it's very entertaining danny
unfortunately at your expense
uh this match but it it was a enjoyable
match and
i know it definitely wasn't much fun to
sit there and take uh
take a bunch of l's today but uh we we
had a good time commentating and i think
the people had a good time watching so
take solace in that cool
congrats lawrence lauren seriously man
good luck man
thank you i i don't know who i'm playing
next but uh yeah i don't know either
on that side of the bracket you'll play
the winner of alina kalashninskaya
i feel like you can you'd be the
favorite in your next match i don't want
to jinx it man
but i feel good about your channel
managed to jinx it quite well but
last year last year i lost the teddy and
he made it to the semis this year he's
going
against the the monster known as karissa
yep so oh yeah he's
important
uh well that's it
yeah all right nothing more for you guys
exactly go enjoy your american football
all right guys thanks very much all
right see you too yeah see you guys
thanks again for for a great match
congrats again laurence all right well
we see that lawrence moves on he faces
the winner of roberto molina and alessia
santoramo
and for danny well his run has
come to an end even before he could get
into a gate here so
well we look across the bracket amman
this one's done but we have another
match in just a few days from now
any i don't know what to say they feel
like they said it all
yeah like that's a great thing about
having danny on the broadcast he just
handles the
interview questions and interview
answers and i feel like that was the
easiest post-game interview i've ever
had to do but yeah we do have
the next match coming up which i guess
is levy and
james canty which we've mentioned
earlier
but now that is the the next thing to
sort of preview
but uh but yeah this is for most people
um pretty one-sided match so we'll
basically see if
if levy can do what his rating says he
should do on paper
yeah these kind of matches not always so
clear-cut when you lose a game you get
frustrated as danny was talking about
today he just
could never find his grasp of this match
and for
lawrence trent he did a great job of
course in his ability to
play an opening that danny wasn't
expecting and that didn't really feel
like he had a good understanding in and
as you said come on we started the show
with this that stubbornness
was causing the players some very big
difficulties
yeah no i feel i almost feel bad calling
it as
accurately as i did because i don't like
to see the matches wind up like that but
that did feel like kind of the story
today robert but
uh yeah a very decisive victory for for
lawrence against
danny and what we thought was going to
be very close match coming into it danny
couldn't find his rhythm and lawrence
was punishing
game after game after game so a big
congrats to lawrence trent on victory
and he'll be moving on in the bracket
i am not a gm tournament for sure and i
want to thank everybody who's been
tuning in for all these hours
of course we want to thank the players
and the production crew who's really
made this such a great show aman i want
to thank you it's been a while since
we've commented together
and i'm definitely looking forward to
more coverage of this event with you
yeah no i'll be i'll be back for uh as
many of these uh
matches in this event as i can so
definitely see some more of me it's been
a while and a pleasure
commentating today with you robert for
sure and
to everybody thank you again enjoy the
rest of your sundays
and tune back in for more chess content
brought to you by chess.com
you